bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream je cherche Kevin et je crois que
que tu es là bienvenue sur le stream
aujourd'hui demiinale du speedips
entre C
et qui va commencer dans un instant
salut Kin j'espère que tu vas bien ça
fait longemp qu'on pas stream ensemble
exactement salut à toi salut à tous bien
content de vousetrouver contente de
streamer ce ce bel événement avec toi
stouf et euh bah content de te féliciter
aussi pour pour ton titre de Mii qui euh
là va arriver très prochainement on sait
que tu l'as obtenu mais qui a pas été
encore officialisé par la FIB tu m'as
expliqué ça que le Congrès
malheureusement bah c'était joué à une
semaine près donc du coup tu attends 4
mois euh c'est quand même pas mal et en
tout cas bravo à toi hyper content pour
toi stouf ça faisait longtemps je sais
que tu attendais ça tu as dû faire faire
des gros efforts parce qu'en plus on
sait que ça c'est parti ça ça s'est
passé dans des circonstances
particulières donc je suis d'autant plus
heureux pour toi tu as fait preuve
d'amnégation et c'est cool quand ça se
passe comme
ça merci merci Kevin pour tes pour tes
on te voit pas sur la sur la sur la
vidéo sur le
stream pourquoi est-ce qu'on te voit pas
Kevin
normalement ouais sur le logiciel ça va
je sais que jeis 20 secondes de décalage
attendre Encel
secondes mais je ne te vois pas B on va
en profiter pour pour rappeler peut-être
un petit peu le format le le temps que
ça se
passe je peux peux le le rappeler si si
ça t'aide le le un petit temps
Stouff donc format du speedchess vous
voyez he en haut à gauche la la scène
est sympa
euh donc on est en en 5 + 1 pour
démarrer pendant 1 heure écart
ouais donc ensuite la cadence ça sera du
du 3 + 1 voilà tout tout tout simplement
avec 50 minutes
et et du coup on sera ensuite sur un
format 1+ 1 le format on va dire Bullet
pendant 25 minutes donc ils ont réduit
stou les les cadences de l'ancien
speedch si on peut peut dire ça sauf fin
la finale qui va revenir comme
d'habitude ok bah c'est c'est bien de le
savoir parce que tu me la prends tu
Voise je t'interrom petitte secondes
juste techniquement est-ce que tu est-ce
que je tu peux m'appeler sur sur discord
et tu enlèves ta caméra d'ici bien sûr
ça marche et enlève le micro aussi du
coup ok voilà un petit problème
technique je tu me rappelles pourquoi je
ne voulais plus
utiliser Google meet pour pour tout ça
et donc il va arriver dans un un instant
notre
ami
et Kevin qui est de retour normalement
oui voilà alors du coup je vais euh je
vais remettre ta caméra du coup parce
que bien en tout cas voilà j'ai eu un
petit souci tu sais
que que ah c'est la magie du direct et
je suis bien content de te laisser la
technique hein Stouff mais ça faisait
longtemps en plus que je que je faisais
plus de de stream pour chesscom et je me
rappelais plus pourquoi est-ce que je
faisais toujours le double truc tu sais
tuens et euh et là je dit benah tiens on
va faire on on va essayer comme ça puis
en fait là je viens de me rappeler
pourquoi est-ce que ça marchait pas du
tout donc je vais ça devrait être ça
devrait être pas mal on a on a ramené on
rappeler pardon les les cadences et euh
on se trouve maintenant avec
IFAN avec les pièces blanches et
Alexandra costeno qui avec les pièces
noires bah deux des des femmes les plus
fortes au monde hein
qui qui sontan c'est euh finalement
après Judit Polgar la meilleure joueuse
de tous les temps si on se réfère au ho
voilà et Alexandra ceno qui est connu
multiples champion du monde et cetera a
elle a un très gros palmarès
les les deux deux joueuses très fortes
sont grand maître mixte évidemment
euh comme les les autres joueurs qui qui
vont vont faire l'autre demi-finale vous
le savez drun Vali et Catarina lagno les
deux joueurs ont été champion du monde
hein faut le Rapp là là c'est très très
fort très très
fort je suis en train de te mettre tes
caméras je vais bientôt faire mon
apparition à côté de Stouff voilà ouais
pour de
bon peu près 10
c'est pas évident de savoir là
qui qui est mieux dans cette position
avec une paire de fou côté blanc mais
des cares noir quand même assez troué on
pourrait voir peut-être un jour un
cavalier arriver dangereusement
F4 pour le moment une pression est
exercée
sur sur Alexandra C avec le fou 4 et la
dame F3 du coup elle joue cavalier F4
mais il y a les motifs de fou pr C6
alors est-ce qu'il y aura du cavalier
prend H3 ça va être compliqué cette
position déjà ouais c'est per de fou
pour les blancs quand
même et robinsin qui met aussi invisible
que sur un terrain de Bat ce Kevin et et
ben tu es pas loin d'une certaine vérité
parce que je suis à nouveau blessé et
c'est un peu la poisse et du coup je ne
serai présent qu'à partir de janvier
pour te donner un peu un ordre
d'idéeinide et après la tendite au cou
c'est tend au talon bref parfois quand
on est joueur d'échec que vaut mieux le
le rester et pas faire trop de de
fantaisie autre dans le domaine du sport
et même les échecs c'est dur en ce
moment en fait tout est dur tout est dur
la vie est dure la vie est dure voilà
dès qu'on qu'on joue dès qu'on est
compétiteur on s'expose à la défaite et
faut les assumer derrière pous bien joué
stouf hein ouais pardon en parlant de de
de de badminton est-ce que tu sais qui a
gagné qui a remporté le tournoi de
badminton de de de du tourno d'Avan
est-ce que Yis auri était
là euh peut-être si s'il était là vu vu
ce enfin vu que maintenant il est R6 R6
c'est quand même un très très joli
niveau je saurais pas dire quel niveau
c'est par rapport aux échec en terme de
de classement ho mais c'est peut-être
1800 2000 je sais pas 1800 allez on va
dire mais 1800 c'est très fort si c'est
une compétition amateur donc s'il était
là euh et je crois savoir qu'il y a eu
des des quelques quelques soirées pour
fêter ton titre mais on m'a dit ça je
connais pas les si tu veux les les
tenant à bout de ces soirées mais c'est
des bonnes soirées apparemment
et je dirais donc Yanis auri je crois
qu'il était dans les soirées non non
mais tu sais que c'était cétait un
tournoi en double ah c'était un tournoi
en double en double C en double ah donc
cétait une paire donc yanisri était sans
doute dans une équipe et toi
potentiellement ou alors pierre Barbeau
peut-être mais bon que soit toi avec ta
raquette ou Pierre Barbeau je sais pas
du tout si tu joues Stouff au badminton
euh mais bon pierre Barbeau non plus
quoi donc du
coup mais fa je suis un peu gêné un peu
gêné à la base je m'étais inscrit avec
des avec des joueurs de enfin des gens
de mon git et au final la veille on a
décidé qu'on avait un peu la flemme puis
moi je faisais un pas un mauvais tournoi
alors je voulais me préparer un peu bien
sûr bien sûr et et puis barbx il sétait
inscrit avec Yanis justement pour jouer
Yanis qui a déjà fait du club quand même
qui j pas mal bien sûr bien sûr main non
c'est un vrai joueur de club en plus he
ouais et et du coup barabix alors il
avait un problème au dos il avit pas
pris ses médicaments pas quoi il avaient
oublié un N et du coup Yanis qui m'a
appelé donc le tournoi commencé à 10h il
m'a appelé à 9h45 tout fa absolument que
tu viennes j'ai pas de coéquipier pour
jouer j'ai dit non mais j'ai annulé et
cetera et tout je commencé à me préparer
et tout
et bon ben je suis allé j'ai pris la
voiture je suis allé le secourir et on a
gagné le tournoi g mat bon c'est qui en
fait moi j'étais là j'aiessayé bon après
à mon humble niveau euh hein j'ai j'ai
pas si mal joué que ça mais ok je suis
tu t'es battu tu t'es battu tu t'es
battu voilà voilà mais bon j'ai pas trop
donné de point ça allit ça allit je
trouve euh mais bon moi encore une fois
je suis pas bon hein tu as une belle
aide tu as une belle aide je pense mais
c'est c'est bien en fait du coup tu as
cartonné tu es passé mettre
à à comment diraisje àan et en plus
tu as gagné le tournoi de badminton mais
ça rase quoi je peux dire
ce c'était pas dur parce que franchement
en fait moi j'étais devant et je prendis
toutes les petites balles et dès que
cétait un peu haut je pouvais un peu
SMER donc tu vois j'avis trava et lui il
courit il courit derrière de partout oui
bien sûr bah ouais c'est c'est vraiment
ça la force au badminton normalement tu
as une mobilité le terrain paraît
toujours plus petit quand bah les
joueurs sont expérimentés ils arrivent à
placer très rapidement sur tout le
terrain ce qui est d'ailleurs ouf quand
tu vois les meilleurs mondiaux comme aux
échecs on se régale quoi quand quand les
joueurs jouent très très bien et déjà un
bon petit niveau amateur ça ça commence
à être à être plutôt pas mal ouais alors
alors cette partie du coup euh ben quand
même une petite pression j'ai envie de
dire des blancs parti avec peut-être ce
foot cl blanche il arrivé à venir en C4
pourrait être pas une mauvaise pièce
faut C reposé hein euh et chacun sa
couleur ouit les Noirs ben les gaz noirs
sont un peu fermés à cause du pion F4
donc même ce P F4 si tu pouvais le
manger je suis pas sûr que tu le
mangerais avec les Blancs hein juste
pour dire qu'en fait et ben ça ouvrirait
bien les cases noires des noir le casse
rouge si je peux si je peux
dire exactement et euh et voilà mais bon
ok c'est une position qui a priori est
égal je vois pas trop trop un résultat
possible mais s'il y en a un jeis plutôt
l'avantage des blancs parce qu'en fait
tout simplement après un coup du style
tour 2 bon tour 2 je pense ça peut-être
nul direct avec T prend dame pr et F3 je
peer
rapidement il y avait le il y avait
quand même le pion de plus
pour pour les blancs donc on pouvait
espérer c'est joli F3 ouais par que
maintenant on va fixer ouais faut qu' là
ça fera quasiment nul direct mais l'idée
c'est que s'il y a pas ça et ben moi je
peux taper sur le pion F7 qui a faible
laisse de la position en fait avec mon
petit fou en C4 essayer de faire un truc
mais bon c'est vrai mais bon je pourrais
aussi faire dame D4 donc bon c'est on
est à peu près à l'équilibre mais tu as
raison d'insister sur le jeu des des
deux camps sur leur couleur en fait hein
finalement chacun joue sur sa couleur F
cé c'est vraiment un jeu d'initiative et
celui qui prend l'initiative peut peut
gagner en fait F6 raté peut-être sououff
d'ailleurs avec les les blancs pour
trouver quelque chose F6 c'est
intéressant ouais
de casser un petit tout à l'heure quand
la tour était en D5 ça avait ça avait
l'air d'être ouais d'être vraiment un
coup logique en fait ce F6 pour essayer
de voilà là on voit l'initiative
d'ailleurs chercher peut-être d' prend
F4 prise3 et match nul que
prochainement probablement ça va répéter
le roi est très faible si vous voulez
dans ces position
là bon la cadence est assez speed he
bien sûr quand qu'and on a le le rajout
temps de une seconde mais juste c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas
grandchose et ça joue HE sont pas
content n
PR3 incroyable gros craquage de qui est
qui en rigole qui en
rigole c'est pas encore totalement
terminé il y a encore les opposé mais
normalement quand même je ça fait peur
oh là là ah mattend un coup incroyable
allez partie suivante aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe Aï Aï Aï Aï a je vous changer le
score avec F de couleur opposé euh ça
été le Big
crack bon y fan je on on sait qu'elle
joue un peu moins qu'à une certaine
époque
ouais le Stouff dans quel
euh
ah ok merci Nico pour le la petite
demande je sais pas si tu as vu stouf au
niveau des sons n'est pas synchro
apparemment je suis beaucoup plus fort
que
toi au niveau du son au niveau du
son je te remercie de
préciser alors je viens de mettre le
micro devant moi je l'avais pas mis
avant et puis et on a une belle
sicilienne agressive d'ailleurs qui
vient de démarrer avec la Sicilienne que
j'aime beaucoup des des deux cavaliers
noirs là qui sortent rapidement qui
offre cette
position je viens de baisser ton son ah
fait je suis bête je comprends pourquoi
j'ai compris pourquoi j'ai complement
oublié mes
écouteurs c'est le problème tu tu
m'attends 2 minutes j'arrive ouais ok
bah de toute façon je continue sans toi
donc on est dans une sienne et deux
cavaliers où il y a une case D6 faible
sur laquelle les blancs vont appuyer là
on a envie de faire petit rock
rapidement et C4 pour appuyer sur cette
case faible en D6 si le cavalier vire de
D5 on va pouvoir appuyer sur la la case
en D6 mais aussi sur le pion arriéré en
D7 donc laav fou B7
est un petit peu plus marginal que dame
C7 l'idée de fou B7 on est en train de
s'en apercevoir ça va être de d'activer
le fou sur la grande
diagonale mais déjà là prochainement on
va pouvoir jouer pour C4 dans dans
d'excellentes conditions les Noirs vont
peut-être se résoudre à à virer le
cavalier de E4 est-ce qu'on peut jouer
un coup thématique comme F5 dans ce type
de position en dame B8 c'est bizarre ce
que font les
Noirs en tout cas Kevin peuttre je peux
jouer F4 cette structure elle me
rappelle un petit match mais ouais tu
vois c'est le le le le thématique voilà
ça s'est mal passé hein pour les Noirs
ouais alors ça généralement c'est pas
jou tout le temps la même variante avec
H4 ouais ouais ouais jouer la vieille
ligne c'est ça c'est intéressant bon ça
donne le pion mais en fait ça empêche le
coup C4 des blan ou parce on reprend
D6 c'est ça c'est queour C4 clou sur
cavalier bouge et avec C4 mainant j'ai
plus pour CER
fafierme je voulais vérifier dame D4
parce que avant de
prendre pr pr G7 et
grand très risqué
ouais donc fou
C4 d D6 dame D4 tu disais non je voulais
faire dame D4 avant avant de prendre en
C4 ah ici ouais avec la men sur C4 et G7
mais d prend D6 d prend G7 grand R pense
que c'est intéressant à montrer ouais et
là il y a les compensations très fortes
ou pas trop elleim pas trop ça la jauge
mais peut-être F F3 mais bon ça fait
quand même peur ASP pyologiqueou dans
ces parties rapides on aime pas trop se
faire attaquer son roi c'est difficile
de réagir je trouve que les Noirs jouent
bien dans leur dans leur malheur ouais
doivent pas être très bien mais ils mett
la pression B3 très bien joué l'idé C4
et fou B2 on ve C4 C C3 n'est pas
possible je prends la dame je prends la
dame je perds le fou et après j'attaque
la
tour ici il faut bouger la dame je crois
qu'on a pas trop le choix B3 hyper
intéressant pour placer aussi le fou
distinctif de case noire en B2 sur la
grand diagonale pour faire mal sur le
long terme ouais donc position qui est à
l'avantage de la joueuse blanche
costenho qui qui démarre bien en fait
son son speed chass qu'elle a gagné de
manière un peu j penséis mais il me
semblait que tour B1 accéléré quand même
les choses il y a eu F les deux alors
onous demand ou parce que tour B1 tour
C8 c'est ce qu'elle a calculer peut-être
tour B1 tour C8 ah ok tour B1 tour C8
j'ai peut-être pas le temps que je fou
B2 à cause de la présence sur le pion 4
effectivement on a une question par
rapport à la nationalité enfin par
rapport au au drapeau drapeau suisse euh
de costenho qui ben oui c'est lié à
c'est lié à ce qui se passe en Ukraine
il a beaucoup oui il y a beaucoup de
joueurs comme ça beaucoup de joueurs qui
qui ont changé de de de de code de code
enfin de voilà pour pour pouvoir faire
des tournois et puis même ils sont pas
d'accord avec ce qui se passe là-bas et
du coup ben ils le montrent en en
changeant de de pays tout simplement
c'est le cas aussi de de vitugof que
j'ai vu donc le le très fort joueur et
amis de nepomi qui était qui est
toujours autour de 27 2750 et qui est
anglais maintenant et qui joue
actuellement euh la Coupe d'Europe par
équipe là où où on a nos représentant
tricolor bah chez les filles qui qui
joue hyper bien et par contre en mix
c'est beaucoup plus dur avec euh nos nos
cinq gars là qui qui ont démarré
mollement hein qui doivent vraiment se
refaire maintenant parce qu' ont perdu
deux match de suite contre des équipes
bien plus modestes que euh la Pologne
qui est quand même une très forte équipe
hein ouais et euh la plus petite équipe
d'Italie voilà pour se refaire quand
même hier euh ils ont réussi à de peu
battre une équipe un peu plus
confidentielle bon euh maintenant euh ça
fait du bien une victoire et j'espère
qu'ils vont se relancer et finir en bout
boulet de Calon c'est Sébastien Mazé qui
a qui a tweeté que ils avaient déjà
réussi un comeback de folie donc il
espérait en tant capitaine revoir ce
comeback de folie on verra bien s'ils y
arrivent SAF je sais pas si tu suis un
petit peu oui je su en tout cas les les
filles ben elles sont en tête pour
l'instant et et encore elles ont raté
contre l'azerbadjan étai en il y Pauline
qui était complètement gagnante qui a
qui a qui a craquer à la fin et malgré
tout ça elles sont encore en tête et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui grosse grosse
épreuve ell vont jouer contre la Géorgie
qui est pour moi l'équipe numéro 1
et et franchement bon bah ok là c'est
l'épreuve un peu
ultime si elle gagne ce match je pense
que il y a plus rien qu' s'arrêtera quoi
on espère en tout cas en tout cas pour
gagner une compétition comme ça il faut
que toutes les joueuses soient en forme
dans l'équipe et s'il y en a un qui fait
un peu défaut ben au mauvais moment ça
peut vraiment tout cassé et là quand tu
regardes les les joueur de l'équipe de
France bah il n pas une qui faitme
tendant qui elles sont toutesou ou puis
a un système de remplaçant en plus qui
permet une petite souplesse quand même
c'est
ça c'est ça bon là c'est en train de de
revenir un petit peu peut-être côté noir
parce qu'on a réussi à éliminer un des
fou mais ça reste un peu plus difficile
quand même puisque les pions noirs se
font plus ciblés que les
pions que les pions blancs
particulièrement le pion D7 sur le long
terme il va falloir trouver du
le F B2 qui est dur à gérer comme nous
le mondeouffe bon on est on est moins
bienc la noir mais on a une bonne
position de contre ouais ouais ouais
ouais c'est
clair des fois il y a même du F4 bon là
deessite ça marchera pas mais tu vois
l'idée en fait tout à l' je pensais de
faire par exemple tour 3 à la place et
essayer un jour de faire marcher un truc
sur la diagonale j'ai même pensé à un
truc que tu as peut-être pas aimé mais
un coup comme G4 pour essayer de faire
H4 G5 et ca il y a plein d'idées en fait
les blancs ils peuvent préparer en fait
j'aime bien et j'aime pas j'ai joué
pendant très longtemps comme ça et ça
peut passer en en partie là sous
pression rapide mais objectivement G4
alors qu'on a plutôt le contrôle de la
position ça doit être un peu trop après
faut que les Noirs dans ce cas-là
prouvent j'aime bien ce qu'elle fait
avec les Blancs elle est en train de
bien construire sa sa position faut pas
oublier quand même que j'ai un pion
passé sur le long terme qui peut aussi
être utile exactement elle tourne autour
de sa proie ce qui est pas mal est-ce
qu'on peut pas jouer tour D3 x 3 pour
revenir elle peut naviguer entre
l'objectif de D6 et l'objectif du roi
mais attention à un contre à un moment
voilà tour des3 elle repart sur le pion
ouis et peut-être E4 à un moment pour
les Noirs E4 qui serait très risqué hein
parce que si les blancs font tour D2 on
a E3 et peut-être du jeu mais bien sûr4
tour D4 et bah le pion D6 la diagonale
ouverte A1 G7 ou H8 mais sur le pion G7
en tout cas ça ça sera problématique
donc E4 c'est un coup très difficile à
jouer j'aime bien aussi son approche du
temps à cost qu'elle met la pression sur
IFAN qui a complètement craqué sous
pression du temps et on sait que c'est
difficile stou bah quand il manque
vraiment du temps on peut craquer donc
FO 3 c'est sans doute tour F6 ah non FO
ouais il y a peut-être des tours prend
D6 en plus c'est déjà pas tour prend 6
dame prendre6 c'est pas facile déjà
dame4 je pense que c'est sage peut-être
cavalier F6 voilà cavalier F6 jou tempo
c'est normal dame 3 pour aller jouer la
petite finale c'est malin avec le temps
oh là là prix à tempo ça donne pas envie
pourtant F PR3 stouf la finale je sais
pas ce que tu en penses mais no les
Noirs en fait en fait ce piomber alors
je sais pas il peut être à la fois fort
et pas fort bien sûr faut voir un peu
les réaction mais c'est vrai qu'ici on a
quand même pas mal les blancs prend tour
B8 sans doute voilà tour
b8ess d'empêcher un petit peu ce
d'avancer
et je jouer fou des deux B4 ouais ilut
mais bon il y a B4 maintenant il faut le
jouer je pense B4 B5 c'est B4 B5 B6 gros
plan a AE aïe on avait le temps c'est
bizarre il a pas joué B4 B5 c'était
vraiment le plan mett le fou 1 3 pour
faire B4 B5 c'est bizarre peut-être
gagner quand même
et après là ça s'acélère ouais non c'est
clair là il le à défendre roi F6
peut-être G6 plutôt bien tour D5 ouais
c'est bien pr B5 maintenant voilà on y
va c'est ce qu'on voulait tout à l'heure
P D6 aussi le P c'est 4 qui aussi qui
peut être un problème aussi F B4 va être
jouer B6 peut-être B6 j'envoie le pion
encore raté intéressant
elle a raté le coup du chaos je pense B6
à nouveau je propose toujours la même
chose tou voilà bah là elle a trouvé a
regretté sans doute de avoir la joué là
ça doit être gagnant mais faut un peu de
travail alle H4 pour faire F F4 qu'elle
pouvait jouer tout de suite je pense
j'avais une idée monstrueuse F F4 G5 C5
et je pense qu'on gagnait mais bon waouh
waouh joli on pourra le montrer après
éventuellement mais bon ça ouais et si
et si ça déconne comme ça on pourra voir
si c'était vraiment bon là c'est
complèement gagnant maintenant F F4
c'est fini juste ah prise il y a C5
aussi qui me plaisait stou ok C5 c'était
hyper cool a avec la pression du temps
on voit qu'il y a des bêtises ouais
elle essaie de gagner quand même avec
tour D1 mais maintenant elle a anéanti
ses chances sous pression du temps j'ai
envie de dire que ce ce pion il va
pe-être être rendu c'est ça tu as raison
Souf k D3 qu' aller jouer tour D4 estce
qu'on joue tour D4 ici pour tenir le
pion à cause de K D3 menace imminante
ouais peut-être c'est le seul coup ça
l'air un peu bizarre mon histoire le
lâche carrément juste
nul est-ce que si tu veux pas essayer un
petit peu quand même les deux joueurs V
les deux joueurs vont peut-être vouloir
essayer là ouais ça parce que avec avec
le temps tout est possible maintenant
hein on voit qu'elle joue très bien mais
que quand il leur reste moins de 15
secondes c'est un peu plus la loterie
nul euh voilà on a vu certains grands
maîtres quand on regarde le speed chess
mixte qui arrive avec cette pression euh
du du temps de temps un petit peu
infernal moins de 15 secondes euh ils
arrivent à garder un petit peu la tête
froide ce qui est extrêmement dur pour
moi moi déjà quand j'ai moins de 30
secondes SV je tilte mais je trouve que
là ouais sous pression du temps on voit
qu'elles sont qu'elles sont vraiment en
difficulté et ça
repart je vais voir si je peux si je
peux vous mettre un peu mieux la vidéo
salut salut à tout le monde qui arrive
ça fait plaisir de de vous retrouver ça
faisait un moment avec Stouff qu'on a
pas pu commenter un événement chesscom
faut dire qu'il y en avait un petit peu
moins et là ça reprend et on va vous
commenter les deux demi-finales donc
première demi-finale aujourd'hui demain
demain 17h Souf ça a pas changé d'oraire
tiens on peut faire le le petit teaser
pour demain demain je crois que j'avais
mis oui demain c'est c'est 17h et la
finale sera lundi à 17h aussi ok super
super
super alors D4 a été joué alors là c'est
une bonne question est-ce qu'on va en E2
ou en B1 toujours la question est-ce
qu'on le replie sur autre case elle est
parti en E2 ouais elle a préféré la
pression dans le doute elle a mis la
pression sur des4 et là peut-être qu'on
peut faire H3 et
B4 je coup qui va va jouerin je pense
c'est obligatoire H3 parce que si tu
joues pas H3 tu pourras plus jamais le
faire paraît logique de de piquer le de
gaz blanche mais j'ai des coups
candidats tour C1 B3 FO 3 elle a joué
pour B4 ça s'entend elle veut
directement mettre la presse c'est pas
mal on aime bien les blancs
Alex Alexandra CAG qui a raté un petit
peu le coche de de prendre un deuxième
point euh
HM l'orqu est 8 bon il y a du temps hein
vous le savez il y aura il y aura
beaucoup de de matchs avec avec cette
formule là je sais pas à combien on va
s'arrêter mais euh on a quand même à il
y aura moins de partie que d'habitude
parce qu'on là on a 75 minutes au lieu
de 90 c'est ça mais
euh 2h de de jeu pur quoi qu'il arrive
entre guillemets donc 2h30 ça laisse
quand même beaucoup de de parties
surtout que vous savez qu'après la
cadence va être réduite au bout d'unh
155 on on passe en 3 + 1 puis après 50
nouvelles minutes on passe en 25 minutes
de 1+ 1 Stouff c'est ça et donc tout
peut arriver he jusqu'au dernier moment
alors deè demale la première demi-finale
he et la deuxème du coup Kevin toi qui a
fait de voir ouais euh je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure donc on aura Catarina lagno et
euh Harik do voilà harika do donora vly
on va on va écorfer son nom c'est ça
voilà donc là encore une fois on a
vraiment le les meilleurs joueuses du
monde hein lagno qui a été qui a été
plusieurs fois champion du monde Blitz
et
rapide et euh et euh et areka qui est
euh ben euh une des meilleures joueuses
indiennes he de tous les temps tout à
fait elle est extrêmement forte et
d'ailleurs on peut dire qu'elles ont mis
des grosses grosses raclé à des super
joueuses euh je peux rappeler les les
résultats des quarts de finale parce que
je les ai sous les yeux
euh Katarina lagno a joué une joueuse à
2300 donc un peu plus un peu moins forte
que les autres quart de finaliste euh
Priyanka nutaki donc joueuse à 2300 qui
a pris un 17,5i 4 et5i
donc c'est pour montrer la différence de
niveau ouais par contre Harik Dr
dronavali pardon était opposé à
Valentina gunina donc une joueuse grand
maître mixte très connue elle a pris 17
et demi 6 et demi Valentina gunina ouais
ouifan c'est défait d'une des grandes
espoirs mondial Paulina
kouvalova 13,5i 7 et demi légèrement
plus serré mais quand même un écart
significatif tandis que costenuk a joué
aussi une des jeunes espoirs
vachali costenuk a battu 13 à 8is donc
quand même des écarts significatif Val
c'est la petite sœur enfin la grande
sœur pardon de Prague
exactement deux points d'interrogation
avec cavalier pr 5 complètementï a AE oh
là là complètement raté par par
cost ça c'est des grosses bvues quand
même en 5+ 1 on VO que les deux joueuses
pour l'instant ça démarre mollement je
trouve qu'elles sont en de ça de leur
niveau habituel parce que là on a on a
quand même deux joueuses qui joue
extrêmement bien aux échecs c'est V une
grand maître mixte et c'est pas des
petits grands
maîtres particulièrement fan qui a été
plus de 2650o donc là c'est elle est
rentrée vraiment dans dans l'élite
mixte cost new son son piicelo doit doit
être aux alentours de 2550 je dirais
stouf oui oui par là ouais
en tout cas donc c'est des joueuses
extrêmement fortes ouis et là c'est big
blunder dans la
première5 c'est pas mal du
tout67 j'aime beaucoup Dami et E5 bon
c'était soit l'un soit l'autre ou les
deux
voilà particulièrementon tous les deux
ouais je pense qu'on est on est pas loin
de 5 ça va fonctionner c'est marrant ce
D prend H3 jeaurais pas pris moi je m'en
foutais un peu pour cavalier H6 elle
veut faire stou cavalier h mat cavalier
H6 ça cavalier forcé ça ça pose des
problèmes complètement foutu combien de
je sont plus 2006 actuellement je crois
qu' a une
oui pas pas je peux vérifier le de parce
que Paul G est encore vivante
mais mais oui oui tuas une seule an la
numéro 2 ça doit
être ça doit
[Musique]
être comment s'appelle
la c'est gorkina mais qui a perdu pas
mal de points
dernière
dernière j'ai vérifié le ho d'Alexandra
C a 2526 actuellement en en partie
longue 26 en rapide et en blit elle est
moins forte 2455 c'est le Hed elle joue
aussi moins de compétition c'est toute
proportion gardé donc on va on va voir
ça et c'est déjà reparti avec la
victoire et l'égalisation d'ifan qui est
favorite dans ce match évidemment au vu
de son CV même si Alexandra est très
forte elle aussi c'est normalement bien
sûr pas pas les mêmes joueuses
an qui est numéro 1
mondial chez les femmes
et elle à peu près elle est très proche
du top 100 mondial alors que Alexandra
costen est à peu près 500e mondial donc
ça fait une une différence très
significative elle est devenue
championne du monde féminin à l'âge de
17 ans si je me trompe pas dis pas de
bêtis et ensuite elle a choisi a préféré
les études à sa carrière
équel et en fait c'est pour ça qu'elle
qu'elle a un peu disparu du monde des
échecs on la voit beaucoup beaucoup
moins elle elle était montée à 2680
quasiment 2007 vers 18 ans ce qui est
assez incroyable et on tout le monde l'
voyait comme la la future pog mais elle
joue plus mais elle joue plus dire elle
joue des compétitions sur Internet voilà
elle joue en dilétante je pense que elle
adore le jeu deschac mais elle s'est
consacrée à autre chose elle en a fait
beaucoup
ouais donc alors hier Diamante
elle a fait nul et et l'équipe a gagné 3
et demi 0 et demi contre l'Arménie donc
là aujourd'hui on va pas suiv suivre
cette compétition on va suivre le speed
chess Championship he c'est la
demi-finale entre IFAN et custigou mais
on suit aussi bien sûr on a parlé tout à
l'heure voilà le championnat d'Europe
d'Europe parce que parce que bah c'est
c'est une grosse compétition et puis la
France en plus dans l'équipe féminine
elle est elle est en tête elle fait un
super tournoi donc c'est cool d' ça joue
aujourd'hui je sais pas à quelle heure
ça joue je crois que ça joue à 15h il me
semble pu c'est vrai qu'on connaît tous
les joueurs en plus que soit l'équipe
l'équipe mixte ou l'équipe féminine donc
on aime bien voir quels sont les les
résultats de de notre élite nationale
ouais et depuis quelques années en plus
on on est de mieux en mieux représenté
qualitativement du coup c'est toujours
plus agréable quand ça gagne à suivre et
c'est vrai que les résultats sont bons
et euh et en plus tiens pour tout dire
je je pars à Kilkenny aussi la semaine
prochaine ce je enfin jeudi prochain
stouf pour aller jouer un très fort open
il y aura matthie cornet et Sébastien
Mazé et Fabien libizevski qui font aussi
ce ce tournoi c'est pas que tu jouer
parce que je j'ai Fabien lizevski qui
m'a qui qui m'a écrit il m'a dit qu'il
allait k k alorsc c'est un tournoit qui
est connu je crois que c'est il y a pas
de classement ho exactement tu tu vois
tu vois pourquoi le risque est quand
même moins ouais mais c'est plus je
crois qu'il y a une belle ambiance
là-bas il a une belle ambiance très
sympathique et c'est pour ça que les
gens vont faire ce tournoi d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien le faire un jour je
ouais bah ça faisait longtemps stouf que
je voulais le faire je te dirais si ça a
tenu ses promesses et j'y vais aussi
avec un de mes collègues d'équipe
jeannoël Rif qui aime bien les tournois
festifs le le joueur alsacien il y a
aussi thbao Fantinel qui est là le le
joueur le maître international d'ingin
euh donc tu vois il y a il y a déjà un
beau plateau de de joueurs français pour
s'amuser aussi sur les chiquers en
dehors hm hm
ouais ouais non sympa belle ambiance en
tout cas le le les personnes que tu m'as
cité sont toutes très sympa et mais un
jour ce tournoi je pense que je chaque
année je le dis mais mais un jour fa
vraiment que j'aille le faire ça a l'air
sympa ouais c'est c'est vraiment là j'en
ai rediscuté avec Sébastien Maé qui gère
un petit peu parce qu'il a l'habitude de
faire ce tournoi là les invitations pour
pour les joueurs français et il m'en a
reparlé pendant que que l'on était au
championnat de France de l'Alpe dues
cette année et et c'est vrai que je me
suis dit allez cette année je le fais
voilà je laisse le bébé à ma conjointe
tu vois Stouff et et du coup je
par aux échec
ouais ouais ouais j'ai réussi à à
négocier à négocier cela au moment où
elle était enceinte et un peu tu vois
dans dans les perspectives d'avoir le
bébé et du coup elle s'est dit bah ouais
c'est cool bon maintenant
mtenant le bébé ne fait pas forcément
toutes ses nuits tout ça dit ou ça
aurait été cool que tu sois là quand
même mais bon c'est négocier c'est
négocié ouais c'est fini petite malice
petite malice ou
mal alors c'est marrant la Jae met
avantage noir j'aurais tendance à dire
cavalier B1 cavalier C3 et je prends
l'avantage avec avec les les blancs
peut-être qu'il y a des problèmes de D5
parce que même si le pion E5 est en
l'air peut-être que D5 peut arriver sur
un un coup de cavalier
B1 que j'ai le droit de faire ça c'est
pas si facile parce que nous on voudrait
venir sur C case là et euh c'est ça
travaille bien en plus côté blanc avec
Alexandra costenuk comment est-ce que je
fais tour B4 A4 à quelque chose comme ça
je peux pas il y a le pion des6 pour
l'instant ou A4 tour A6 pour essayer de
ouais j'y pensé mais au pire tour à 3 je
sais que c'est pas beau mais
ouais je fais un pressing après je sais
pas simplement7 K5 est-ce que je peux
jouer ça à un moment oui K7 K5 à 4 voilà
bah ouais et là c'est quand même
beaucoup plus de contre-chance si les
Blancs avaient réussi à stabiliser
ouais5 du couon intermé cavalier E3
était pas fou fou finalement bien jouéin
on voit que là les les les jeunes femmes
ne sont pas pressées par le temps et du
coup bah c'est très qualitatif ce
qu'elle nous propose à la fois cenho qui
voulait visser un peu wifa etan qui ici
arrive à trouver de l'oxygène un Stouff
avec A4 ouais d A3 menace B4 essayie de
s'en sortir comme ça parce qu'il y a un
clouage sur sur la tour je peux pas
manger en B3 à cause d'un point à8 dame
B7 point d'exclamation alors qu'est-ce
qu'elle a vu sur tour D6 et êche tour D6
c'est la question je vais peut-être
manger ici c'est posé comme question
mais il y a prend B3 vraisemblablement à
tour prend D6 et à prend B3 ah bien sûr
là il y a B2 qui arrive et et ça va être
terminé sur
bien
vuan de là c'est beaucoup plus dans ces
standards parce que dans les deux
premières parties céit des grosse gaff
puis domination assez nette d'Alexandra
costenuk et elle vient de se reprendre
sur les deux dernière partie avec deux
parties très abouties heouf est en train
de montrer et de s'imposer en patron
après deux parties un démarrage vraiment
en mode diesel là ça va être
signature ça va être termin d B quiment
forcé pour empcher B2 et tu je prends
cavalier à B2 mais ah ou ou ou là c'est
même
plus même peut-être ouais au tour à 2 je
me disais tour à de pour en
ouais y a pas de mat du couloir il y a
la petite porte qui a été
effectué donc
couos ça le fait tout seul
alors je m'attends à l'abandon je sais
pas ce que tu en penses mais alors ça a
dû être joué je pense que je
vois moi aussi jeavais pas actualisé T2
ét joué St et là on a envieouer pas
c'est le coup qui qui m'intéresse le
plus ah ouais j'avais envie de garder tu
vois bah j'aurais joué peut-être tour à
deux mais ça c'est bien avec cavalier
c3ou même fou à de j'avais j'aimais bien
les perspectives de tour à 1 et ben là
cavalier C3 est-ce que ça marcherait pas
quand même ah bah je voulais faire c C3
tour à ah ok ouais F 2 c'est plus fort
quand même FO 2 c'est c'est très bien
même esprit on vire la dame ouais on la
chasse pour faire dame derrière et c'est
abandon bon elle a elle est parti on
voit d'ailleurs le le pourcentage
chesscom de cette
partie sur notre écran on voit que elle
a joué à 97 % au IFAN ou qui est
vraiment une partie longue de qualité
donc là elle a fait mal quand même
franchement j'étais assez étonné de son
niveau sur les deux premières parties
qui n'était vraiment pas bon par rapport
à ce qu'elle fait d'habitude et j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a joué de manière
excellente pour son niveau les deux
suivantes elle a fait extrêmement mal
hein ouais bah des fois des fois il faut
rentrer un petit peu dans le bain tu
vois des fois il faut euh juste tu as
besoin de quelques parties de chauffe
pour pour te tu vois pour rentrer et
euh tu vois moi je je connais souvent
mes élèves avant un tournoi en c'est une
partie une partie lente ou même un
tournis de Blitz ou ou un rapide ou quoi
que ce soit toujours essayer de faire un
petit peu de un petit peu de de tactique
euh avant d'y aller tu vois juste un
quart d' 20 minutes quoi histoire de
rentrer dans la partie avant que la
partie commence tu vois c'est marrant
parce que tu sais
euh je donc je joue dans une équipe de
de Top 16 qui est hyper compétitive
depuis un moment avec des joueurs
indiens très forts puisqu'on a naragan
on a Sarine on a
mendongka maintenant on a aussi le
joueur allemand très fort blue bahom
mais en tout cas pour les Indiens Leon
mendonka qui a vraiment extrêmement
progresser qui est 2650 à 18 ans si je
dis pas de bêtises euh et donc
fait partie de de l'élite future on
verra à quel niveau mais il fait des
sprints de problèmes juste avant ses
matchs des sprints de 3 minutes comme un
gros bourrin tu vois il fait ça et il
adore ça comme un enfant et c'est
exactement l'application strict de ton
conseil quoi alors que il il a boîre
2650 bah il fait ses petites tactiques
comme un enfant et ben s'il le fait
c'est que il doit y trouver un un
intérêt c'est pas les grosses études
c'est juste un peu de tactique pour se
réveiller et
pourle euh par contre nous quand on
était en Top 12 avec les Pragues et les
gkch et ben c'était des grosses études
qui ressemblaient à rien au petit DJ
ouais et bon c'est un peu différent mais
dans l'idée tu vois c'est vraiment euh
de s'entraîner tu vois et tout ça en
fait je crois que ces genl il faisait
pas trop de préparation théorique mais
c'était beaucoup plus euh euh tactique
tu vois tactique général voilà euh on
faire une petite pause rapide Kevin
parce que j'ai euh j'ai quelques pubs à
à vous montrer enfin oui en fait il y a
il y a il y a une pause pendant le speed
chest pendant la première séquence de 5
+ 1 en fait à chaque pause enfin à
chaque milieu de de segment il y a une
pause sauf pour le Bullet je crois que
ça va ça va ça enchaîne ok bon B c'est
bon à savoir je vous envoie la pub de
toute façon j'ai qu'une seule pub à vous
montrer aujourd'hui donc après on sera
pas obligé de faire des Paes tout le
temps hein c'est comme on veut voilà je
on se rrouve dans 5 minutes ou même pas
ça va reprendre bientôt bah 3 minutes 5
minutes par je vous dis à tout de suite
à tout de
[Musique]
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin qui
a disparu sur mes
caméras mais ne vous inquiétez pas il
est là
Kevin
hop je mes
trucs super et du coup on va
arriver sur une nouvelle position c'est
parti très vite hein Stouff on a une
structure
assez
classique imaginer ça peut être une
structure de carocan d'échange pu que
c'est un peu la thématique du jour on a
vu quand même pas mal de de carreaux
mais on peut l'obtenir par différents
système et apparemment c'était et le
grand rock blanc le laisse aussi
présager c'était un des buobava avec les
Blancs pour pouran St ouais je vous
remontre ça rapidement je vous mets le
h voilà le
dérouler voilà donc la classique pour
l'instant et fou G4 très très rapide qui
est un peu moins joué g la paire de fou
pour les blancs mais une position
vraiment très stable avec les pièces
restantes là c'est vraiment une position
de carocan d'échange de gambame inversé
avec position quand même assez
équilibrer juste des bizarries avec les
pions F3 et H4 qui laisse peut-être la
possibilité au blanc de de s'étendre
tout simplement de ce côté-là ouais donc
vraiment pas de problème pour les blancs
ici hein avec l'idée de faire H5 H4 H4
H5 pardon pour les blancs et d'avoir
provoqué H6 et ben souvent il y a le
coupour G4 j' par regardez elle
travaille le pion G7 et ça provoque les
petits trous il y a un problème
maintenant sur le pion E6 qui peut
éventuellement un jour arriver donc
c'est vraiment qualitatif ce qu'elle
propose IFAN depuis donc ça c'est trème
partie franchement euh si elle continue
comme ça elle va être limite injouable h
que je pense que plus la cadence va se
réduire plus ça va être difficile pour
Alexandra costenuk c'est mon ressenti
moi je suis pas sûr on
VO je suis pas sûr parce que euh tout à
l'heure on a vu hein wi fan qui a ét un
peu fébrile dans dans
les ouais mais elle était pas encore
elle était pas encore en mode
en mode gagnant com comme elle l'a fait
là les deux premières parties pour moi
elle était pas du tout à son niveau réel
ouais et maintenant mais je pense
franchement que je pense franchement que
que Bullet bullette ça va être plus
serré en tout cas bon là il y a 2 et
demi 1 et demi c'est qume ass serré pour
l'instant oui bien sûr mais fan je pense
que la cadence sur laquelle elle peut
vraiment mettre la pression c'est ça va
être le 5 plus n pas très bien joué au
départ F4 est joué ça y est le pion6 il
est ou il est foutu pour toute la partie
peut-être ça ça et taper sur sur le pion
oui puis ton coup F5 il existe puisquil
y a pas E5 à cause du R A7 peut-être
qu'elle va anticiper jou86 d'ailleurs
tour2 tour E3 d'ailleurs je préfère pour
avoir dame 2 dans certains cas elle joue
f5oue F elle joue quand même sur5 elle
va manger probablement je voulais
attendre un petit peu avant de me lancer
dans cette aventure
aisé
elle spécule je pense t sur le vis-àis
Tour d'ame5 prend54 quelque chose comme
ça comme ça
intéressant donc peutêtre qu'on ferit
tour prend5
sur5 prend prend pour essayer d'enlever
la dame du
vis-àis ça l'air quand même difficile
cavalier c'est le même problème
ouais cavalier c'est le même problème
donc t prend forcé peut-être et prend
ouais et là va y avoir des risques de
tour1 dame C5 tour1 tour6 je r inement
j'aime bien dame C5 on a l'impression de
de bloquer toutes les pièces il a
peut-être dame 7 mais bon la finale est
mauvaise bon là c'est c'est une galère
F5 bien joué encore ou super la vitesse
d'exécution en plus est importante parce
que F5 on a l'impression que les Noirs
pourra peut-être revenir dans la partie
elle a considéré que le le vis-à-vis de
la dame était suffisant pour se lancer
joli hein ouais non c'est c'estz ça assz
Impressionnant la vitesse à laquelle
elle joue F5 parce que première vue ça a
pas l'air si génial que ça mais en
fait en fait c'est on a envie en plus
tou de de garder le contrôle dans ses
positions quand on a F4 la faiblesse en
E6 elle se lance dans F5 qui
déséquilibre la position par qu'il faut
plutôt faire qu'on est mal et je crois
que c'est plus efficace elle a saisi le
moment où elle allait peut-être faire
très mal al A5 c'est pas mal pour faire
B4
pour pour faire peur et si les Blancs
jouent B4 eux-mêmes peut-être que
maintenant on pourra essayer E5 pour
mettre du troupe dans la
position il y a eu prise et B4 ouais
c'est ce que je voulais faire avec les
blancs mais peut-être C4 là ouais C4
enore et prise fou prend et je défends
atique
ouais ça a l'air ça l'air pas bon là C5
qui est menacé aussi et ça va être
difficile là pour Alexandra ouais je je
crois qu'elle joue super bien euh pour
l'instant fan là depuis trois parties
elle va elle est en pass de mettre une
troisème un troisème point parce que là
vraiment c'est dur la position ouais
cavalier A5 bien joué quand même un
petit peu de contre-jeu il faut trouver
encore
pe-ê bien joué ce cavalier
A5 comment est-ce qu'on peut conter
faire B3 peut-être B rigol ça peut être
pas mal mais ça fait c'est un peu risqué
quand même hein c'est ça après j'ai plus
personne devant mon roi mais bon j'ai
des menaces concrètes les
3ame qui qui navigue c'est coup très
créat sympa à voir d'ailleurs B3 moi
j'aime beaucoup B3 mais elle a peut-être
vu B3 le problème c'est de le jouer
maintenant tu vois c'est il y a une
différence pour nous en tant que
commentateur où on peut penser à B3 on
trouve ça joli et le problème c'est faut
que ça soit efficace en partie donc
c'est pas que jouer les les coups qui
sont sympas elle a envie de gagner on a
fait une grosse partie avec les les
blancs mais B3 qu'est-ce que tu joues en
fait avec le noir je suis gêné je suis
euh vraiment très très géné je vois pas
bon faire un coup de tête tour C7 là c
non mais elle l'avait vu elle l'avait vu
je pense très vite euh sans doute plus
vite que nous et elle a mis du temps à
le jouer parce que c'est casse- guueule
visuellement parlant peut-être D5
maintenant is D5 j'aime bien que elle
veut contrer peut-être costuk avec tour
a 7 tour A6 ça serait assez logique euh
C prend C4 pis on prend C4 et tour à 6
et tour à 7 le tout pour le tout
ou mais il y a C5 sans doute qui une
extrémist et voilà ça c'est ça peut
faire peur hein tu vois ça peut vite
venir j'ai les pion qui avance vite mais
mon roi aussi pour l'instant il y a la
dame peut pas s'infiltrer encore c'est
ça qui tour 2 c'est bien encore
hein vir un peu en en A2 protéger le roi
menace C5 attention oh là dame à 3 dame
à 6 non mais j'ai5 là
ah ouais euh ok j'ai des échec menace
rien dam 6 menace rien bah quand même ça
menace dam 1 bah pas encore ah pardon
oui ça tuas pas la tour j'ai j'avais
j'avais échec et d'Amel qui était aussi
intéressant qui couvrait un pe tour de
ultra mignon tour B2 empêche tour A7
tour prend B3 échec et dame B2 super
bien joué puis tour B3 aussi qui arver
à la fois simple et et maintenant elle
va envoyer les pions he j'ai aussi ch
aidé hein mais bon ça me découvre quand
même pas mal mon
mon peut-être il y a un coup qui est
vraiment très très esthétique c'est C6
tour à 7 dame prend 7 ou ça c'est mais
il faut calculer bon c'est chaud c'est
chaud c'est chaud parce que tu vas
essayer de remettre tes tours tu
veux le roi il estme peu réseau y a
toujours tour à 4 qui pourrait être une
menace donc c'est un peu trop donc elle
va assurer proprement comment on assure
proprement 26 secondes attention c'est
le ça sera une belle
escroquerie elle se bat C mais elle a
été dominée et du coup elle est en train
d'essayer de de gigoter dame D2 estce
qu'on peut jouer
D2 je
peux aim pas du tout pourquoi bon c'est
très tendu d 5 manqu tour des 3 bon coup
tu as vu comme c'est chaud malgré la
domination d'an le fait que qui joué
pour l'initiative elle réussi à la
troublé et on a vu que la
des des possibilités
ou je crois que je crois que rosem dans
le chat il y avait tour D4 sur dB 2
peut-être ça l'idée hein ouais c'était
pas facile à voir à tempo roiss c'est de
mauvais côté mauvais côté pouran P me
cacher qui pouvit faire roi à de tour à
3 c'est quoi le trou dame C1 ça a l'air
de prise prise dame C1 et la dame C1 roi
là il faut encore mat dame C1 roi D3
tour dame C4 peut-être est-ce que dame
C4 on gagne pas sûr je gag un truc
iil est
le elle tente ok ben écoute belle belle
remontée he sur
d'alexand je pense cette victoire qui
fait du bien qui fait du bien Suisse
elle a en plus respecté ce que tu as dit
c'est-à-dire que dans le mononetime elle
a été plus performante qu'ouifan mais
c'est vraiment aussi le le caractère de
la position qui a amené la
victoire de costenou parce que le le
elle était foutue costenou mais elle
avait de la pression sur sur le roi
adverse donc c'était difficile de de ne
pas craquer avec les Blancs elle a été
très pratique ouais is trouver
le trouver le jeu dans ces position où
tu es vraiment mené enfin c'est
difficile hein parce que là c'était
vraiment le gros Hine quoi
aïe aïe alors là il y a bler reprends le
7 en un coup tu prends le 7 d'un prends7
et tu joues les TR derrière ouais
ça a l'air de perdre du matériel on peut
tester A5 ah ben non A5 c'est j'aggrave
mon cas avec C prend B4 et F prend B4
l'inverse ah oui oui bah je voulais
faire s
B4 de tu les deux les deux tout per donc
sec ça paraît quand même suspect à
première vue c'est bizarre qu' jé a été
joué par par costenho qui est peut-être
que
est elle est un peu tilté par la
situation c'est marrant parce que C3
n'est pas très appréci par les Blancs
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait jouer à la place
stouf est-ce que tu as vu mieux
peut-être dame D2 ouais dame D2 je me
suis dit A5 mais je mange enc ah
maintenant fut prend B4 toujours parce
que le fou était en C8 ouis oui d'accord
c'était la même histoire mais pourquoi
du
coup tricher un coup là pourquoi dame
des2 est meilleur pourquoi Dame des de
est meilleure pourquoi C3 c'est pas bon
juste parce que on est vite fou G4 on
évite F G4 fou G4 il y aurait eu fou
prend B4 et cavalier E5
ouais en fait tu dis
que dame prend F3 F F1 ouais mais j'ai
des problèmes un peu pour ma pièces
voilà exactement il aurait pas eu ces
problèmes là donc doit se dire quean
elle a un peu de chance de trouver des
ressources et c'est le cas mais elle
aurait pu jouer Dame des de pour ma part
je voulais jouer C3 comme elle ouais
beaucoup
plus standard d'attaquer avec un pion
pour être sûr de gagner la pièce oui oui
bien sûr on est conservateur des fois va
pas être très très contente de du sort
c'est vraiment le speedch c'est beaucoup
d'émotions en peu de temps hein stou
puisque oifan fait elle a fait une
partie fantastique après avoir gagné
deux fois et un début très modeste et là
elle elle vient de de craquer son
avantage puis de de donner une pièce en
un coup donc c'est vraiment le mental
qui n'a pas suivi sur ce moment-là du
speed chess assurément je pense qu'elle
va se reprendre ah je pense quand même
les jeux sont quand même professionnels
et ont l'habitude de ce type de
de scénario quand même quand on quand on
joue des parties même o fan à son niveau
il y a plein de parties euh où on se
fait arnaquer où on gagne pas les
parties gagnantes hein ça arrive hein
donc là bon c'est speed chess c'est du
Blitz hein ça va vite hein mais même en
parti l tu vois ça arrive donc ça bon
euh il faut juste qu' qu' gagne une
partie et et ça va repartir mais là
minutes dans ce première portion de
temps en 5 plus une et fan qui est mais
qui est perdante complètement dans cette
dans cette position il y a quand même un
peu de travail dans cette position quand
même stouf là elle a réussi à trouver
des des
ressources c'est pas si facile que ça
parce que F prend 4 puis on prend E4 bon
cavalier E5 c'est sans doute forcé sinon
il y a des E3 mais il y a un peu de jeu
d'un coup qui qui est présent
elle a trouvé mais
IFAN elle est maline elle va jouer tout
à fond en se disant B je vais essayer de
mettre la pression a temps ouais il y a
encore un peu de travail la position est
déséquilibrée certes on voit que les
blancs sont mieux avec deux pièces
contre une tour mais il y a du boulot
encore on va voir si Alexandra costenou
à les
ner alors fou F5 ici a l'air standard le
fou il est en prise le pion 4 aussi est
en
prise il faut qu'elle trouve des idées
pour compliquer ici
ouais alors quel pourrait être le plan
ah bah c c'était pas un bon coup fou F5
et pourtant ouais on pouvait jouer fou 6
peutre la pression sur B3 et le la
centralisation du Fou des fou en D5 mais
bon mais moi j'aimis bien mettre le
Caval en E3 parce que comme tu as parlé
du fait que le E3 ça pouvait être une
ressource tactique c'était le thème
ouais c'était le thème tout à fait ouais
mettre le cavalier ici éventuellement
mettre l'autre cavalier en C45 ramener
la dame à un moment donné quelque part
par par là ça peut être D5 aussi D5 peut
être un coup après pour ouvrir le fou B2
clairement clairement trompé elle s'est
trompé là fan dans son contrejeu mais
c'était une position difficile ouais
Caval 3 et d'ailleurs voilà mais là il y
a tout plus Jama de fois H3 à cause du
cavalier qui tient tout faut tenter F5
F4 mais bon c'est dur à mettre en place
ça va laisser du temps ça va laisser du
temps en blanc ouais non ça m'a l'air ça
m'a l'air foutu hein là D5 j'aime bien
j'aime bien chez Caval C4 oui on voit
qu'ifan patoge un peu mais parce que la
position est extrêmement difficile donc
elle a pas ses points de repère habituel
dans une position Scine et et normal et
du coup là par contre Alexandra kenou
elle a bien verrouillé ses pièces elle
va faire cavalier DC4 D5 elle va
améliorer ses pièces tranquillement mais
ce cavalier qui est venu en en E5 C4
puis E3 je pense que c'est quand même
c'est quand même une idée superbe vous
voyez encore une fois si je reviens un
tout petit peu en arrière dans cette
position un des seuls une des seules
chances des noir c'est un jour essayer
de faire TR pour ouvrir les case noire
essayer de ramener la dame Esser de
faire des choses et là ce qu'elle a fait
vraiment elle a sécuriser complètement
en mettant le cavalier ici pour défendre
le roi empêcher la la la la poussée et
c'est vraiment
hyper un peu oublié par fan d'ailleurs
pédagogique hein ce qu'elle fait hein
ouais alors qu'elle cherche surtout à
gagner mais en plus c'est propre ah
ouais non mais ouais c'est clair
techniquement c'est c'est bien ce
qu'elle fait
fan aurait pu s'envoler je pense en
gagnant la partie précédente et ouis à
l'inverse
ouais alexandra kenou a égalisé au lieu
d'être à Mo- 2 et en plus elle sort une
très jolie partie bon faut dire que IFAN
l'a bien aidé en gaffant très vite mais
sans doute choqué par le fait qu'elle
n'ait pas gagné la partie précédente
ouais maintenant elle se bat
fan mais
moins dangereusement qu'Alexandra kenou
dans la partie précédente où Alexandra
kenou était aussi très dominé avec une
jauge du Makabi mais une position
beaucoup plus casse guueule à jouer là
c'est simple pour les blancs maintenant
il y a pas de menace sur leur roi et
elle va pouvoir convertir juste en
faisant gigoter les pièces normalement
ouais même dame à 6 donne envie ici la
Jae n'aime pas mais honnêtement ça
paraît extrêmement difficile à jouer
pion qui va avancer tout les pièces sont
actives pe plus bizar ouverte quand même
ouais contrôlé par par le cavalier fou
D4 fou C5 faut faire attention à 5 à4
mais bon quand même c'est c'est
vraiment du bonheur à jouer pour les
blancs faut qu'elle joue juste assez
vite pour ne pas se mettre en grande sa
note faut faire un peu attention parce
que dans les positions où une tour peut
dominer deux pièces c'est quand j'ai un
pion passé et que j'ai du jeu et et donc
là je peux me créer ce pion passé
éventuellement un jour de ce côtél avec
les Noirs si jamais j'arrive à faire ça
ça et à me CR passer la tour à ce
moment-là peut-être pourra être pas mal
toute façon on voit queelle a un peu
balbué là ses échecs Alexandra kb6
calier C4 revient mais elle se dit c'est
stable donc c'est pas trop grave ouais
puis pasentré pour la tour tu vois la
Tour Noire même si jamais j'avais la
colonne je pouvais pas rentrer à cause
des des fous et des cavaliers qui cont
toutes les pièces toutes les cases
pardon tout à fait donc ça reste quand
même assez
stable joue vite ouais c'est malin il
faut mettre la pression alors H4 bien
évite tout tous les mats de couloir hein
stouf ouais est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu
pense coup G4 pour amener le roi après
en G3 oui c'est très bien joué je ne
savais pas s'il fallait faire roi H2 roi
G3 roi F4 ou G4 d'abord là elle fait H5
en tout cas c'est bien c'est des petites
améliorations et c'est dur de trouver
des coups avec les noirs on sait pas
quoi faire en fait avec les Noirs donc
dans les positions on sait pas quoi
faire avec le manque de temps c'est une
galère
elle a envie de jouer vite je pense mais
c'est dur bon ah la K C6
d'accord et qu'est-ce qu'on joue là on
va voir qu des4 avec gain de tempo hein
peut-être tour à 8 à 5 à 4 on tente
allez tente elle a tenté c'est pas mal
hein parce que à 5 à 4 ça fait un petit
contrejeu ah ouais non c'est ce qu'il
faut hein c'est ce qu'il faut D6 a été
joué menace D7 alors roi E6 il y a
cavalier D4 il a fourchette ça trois
pièces pour la ça fait trop comment je
défend euh ça l'air très très dur fou ah
fou B5 bien joué contrôle la case
par parce que
a a T cavalier prend B4 pas trop ça
quand même j'aime pas trop pion qui
était quand même notre plus gros
avantage il disparaî encore heureusement
pas simple encore pour
ouis elle c'est elle aurait pu récupérer
peut-être différemment le pion pour
éviter ce thème là mais c'est compliqué
donc ça reste s gagnant quand même tout
en prise il a les deux pions je des
flèches jeess de changer de couleur de
flèche parce que quand je fais des
flèches roues sur rou vous voyez
pas mais
PR7 de PR6 par
exemple elle est bien lucide C dans dans
sa conversion même si tout n'a pas été
parfait on peut le comprendre parce que
il y a des grands des deux
côtés on essaie d'embêter pour que le
roi s'infiltre par B4 donc là il faut
faire un petit coup d'échec fois 3 voilà
c'est joué ouais maintenant il y a plus
d'infiltration
ok cavalier échec cavalier E3 attention
il y a Mme des réseaux de math hein si
je fais ici ouais ouais il faut faut pas
pas jouer trop longtemps d'ailleurs elle
est partie en C6 et là le problème c'est
le pion H6 hein voilà le problème du
pion H6 do falloir toujours surveiller
une fourchette là et la fourchette qui
tombe ah Aï mêre abandon direct bon là
IFAN elle a montré une fébrilité comme
tu l'avais dit sououff Tu as été
visionnaire
au niveau de la fébrilité un peu
tactique que là c'est des grosses
bourdes
ouais attends faut que je mette le
score celui-là
hop et donc costenou qui passe devant de
nouveau dans ce match avec 3 et demi à 2
et demi alors que là on vient de
jouerise ni mat ça augmente hein parce
que c je trouve qu'elle répond très très
bien à à iifan qui a augmenté dans les
rondes 3 et 4 son niveau de jeu elle a
réussi à s'en sortir au combat Alexandra
kossenou dans la ronde 5 et la ronde 6
elle a gagné proprement sur une
bvue initiale mais c'est bien mieux
maîtrisé alors ce qui est bizarre c'est
le temps D4 F5 alors est-ce que j'ai les
coups qui arrivent quand même ouais non
va laisser 3 jouer mais après une action
hyper importante
ouais et on y va on y va on voit que
elle a envie de se faire plaisir
IFAN ce gros
H4 façon un peu
ouais elle a besoin un mais elle a un
peu il c'est'est pass quoi début de
partie qu'elle a réfléchi 40 secondes
pour rien pour le trouver le système
qu'elle a joué contre la Hollandaise
ok bon H5
B6 thématique souvent quand le Fou est
parti position venir cavalier4 qui
peuvent arriver ouais on fait un peu
n'importe
quoice que je joue
TR bien c peut-être forcé on avait pas
le A3 thématique dame pr B2 cavalier à
4isque la case B5 nit pas couverte 4 été
jou très
bord quand Mme OK c'est le thème on va
jusqu'au bout ouais ouais
c'est marrant c'est c'est tu sais il y a
peut-être on mange tout et on joue3 tu
sais pour faire une partie totalement
créa mais c'est dangereux
3 D des de c'est intéressant ce qui se
passe parce que si jamais j'is mangé H6
à la fin j'aurais pu avoir des idées
avec le3 et damage 5 toi tu propos
E3 aussi empêcher un peu développement
des pièces mais je j'aime beaucoup je
trouve que Alexandra cinou joue très
bien elle se laisse pas bluffer elle
joue simple quand votre adversaire joue
bizarre quand vous jouez simple souvent
c'est pas mal le le J le votre votre
adversaire peut s'enfoncer dans un bluff
ou dans des coups un petit peu
aléatoires on va voir si euh ça arrive à
assumer son jeu ça garde la case G6 au
cas où si une dame venait ici c'est
plutôt c'est très sympa tu le dit he
cavalier 7 G K D7 super c'est c'est bien
c'est tout à fait normal alors par
contre donc vous avez le mode d'emploi
ouais mais si je continue par exemple si
je Roque il peut y avoir quand même
prise suivie de foupran là
ouais donc je fais GH d'abord et comme
ça j'ai pas ce problème là c'est bien vu
sou prise fprend fprend tour prend grand
R c'est la partie en en tout cas ce qui
est bien là pour tout le monde c'est
qu'on voit véritablement qu' qu'en grand
maître Auk face à un début un peu créat
un peu bizarre un peu romantique et ben
elle joue normalement aux
écheacs des fois vous êtes étonné quand
votre adversaire ne joue pas théorique
ce qui est un peu le cas d'ifan dans
cette partie elle a joué romantique et
ben il faut s'appuyer sur les principe
d'ouverture et pas
sur des des plans préconçus pas faire de
parkerœur surtout et juste jouer aux
échecs allez E5 peut-être là E5 ça
serait vraiment le coup de la situation
ce serait normal qu'elle le joue ou tour
G8 voilà c'est les coups naturels ouais
avec un roi blanc au centre on aur quand
même en de faire bouger les choses un
truc comme ça al très très logique
avantage avantage a un petit pion en
mangeant à deux mais bon ça on on va pas
trop trop aimer ce genre de choses parce
que tu as rien à faire en A2 la dame
elle est quasiment perdue puis en plus
il y a du contrejeu sur le roi là-haut
donc que 5 qui ét jou est-ce qu'on joue
C3 est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on prend elle
a pris confiance queenio qu'elle joue de
mieux en mieux ouais c'est clair
is mais c'est vraiment jeu de confiance
en fait parce que la partie qui a tourné
qui était complètement gagnante pour
oifan si avait gagné elle aurait monnaé
de de de trois points je crois ouais
c'était plus deux mais au lieu de
l'égalisation mais en plus avec une
confiance qui avait changé de camp parce
qu'elle aurait aligné trois victoires
d'affilé c'est ça et euh avec un super
jeu c'est ça et et là bon il y a eu une
partie enfin qui a été enfin fin une
partie assez incroyable qui est tourné
en faveur de costtigho qui est et qui a
vraiment fait tourner euh cet aspect un
petit peu euh euh psychologique hein
parce que euh la partie d'après oan qui
perd une pièce au bout de 10 coup ex
tout à fait et euh et puis après
maintenant se met Jer des trucs bizarres
c'est ça et cou répond très bien je
trouve hein là elle elle a elle a pas
cédé à la panique euh qu'aurait pu
provoquer ce genre de d'histoire là de
de
débpr et tr qui peut arriver ah non il y
a tpran pardon
je pensais à un truc comme ça quand même
chaud et manger ici en fin de variante
mais tend toujours mais tu peux faire la
même et juste croquer le pion E5
cavalier contre fou le roi dans le
désert ça évite que le cavalier Vienne
en F4 je préfère l'éliminer d'abord par
que là cavalier F4 ça va être pénible
donc je préférais éliminer le
cavalier et après faire cavalier prend5
et
là bah les les tours sont trop bien
passé sécurité du roi le motif
stratégique numéro 1 bon ça ça va être
quand même hyper chaud he stouf cette
position je pense que tu aimerais pas
trop la jouer avec les noir je veux bien
mais mais avec les Blancs c'est pas le
rêve effectivement c'est pas le rêve il
y a eu cavalier prend5 elle laisse
cavalier F4 a laissé cavalier F4 bah je
peux dire qu'elle son'en est pas privé
ouais cavalier
G6
euh là il a pens est-ce que G3 c'est un
coup essayer de bétonner de bétonner je
mets un petit pion F4 il y a eu prise en
G6 fou pr menace d' pr E3 donc il y a eu
dame D4 bien joué bon elle va refuser ah
ouais mais il y a le pion à 7 donc pion
à 7 ça fait cogiter en en en partie de
ce
format on peut jouer dame C7 parce qu'on
m dame G3 mais il faut être sûr quoi
ouais ça ça
ça ça que c'est quand même assez elle a
pris ah oui d'accord ok c'est très
bizarre par parce que maintenantah c'est
blanc qui sont en fait oui avec B45 ça
pour ouais il y a quand même le problème
pour l'instant sur les pions G2 et F2
ouais mais en fait si tu arrives à je F
H5 à un moment
donné miam miam alors ça ça comment je
défends F4 ouis F4 ou F3
ok B3 je commence à aimer aimé quand
même à aimé les blancs dans cette
position je trouve que ce pion h il peut
faire défaut en fin de partie
ou mieux fait de jouer tour Hin pour
éviter ce genre de coup parce que le fou
était très actif on fixait la la pièce
adverse mais on on excuse he évidemment
il y a moins de temps pour enfin pas de
temps pour les deux joueuses allez
maintenant on pourrait dire qu'après
tous ces petits rebondissements on peut
présager d'un match nul dans cette
partie stouf ouais je pense après faire
attention parce parce que si par exle tu
échanges le pion h contre le pion g par
exemple enant tour Hin tour prend tour
échec et tour F1 par exemple he et ben
en fait euh faut faire attention qu' a
mon roi qui peut s'infiltrer hein des
fois mais bon tu vois là maintenant la
tour elle est passive
elle pourra gérer peut-être l'avancée du
du roi du roi noir est-ce qu'
perspective de gain est-ce qu'un plan du
style bon là c'est un peu dommage avec
ça à 4 euh mais ou ou avec mes tours
c'est tour F1 pour mettre une tour en
F4 est-ce que tu aimes bien ce genre de
plan essayer d'échanger une tour par
tour H1 et ramener euh c'est pas mal là
j'ai j'ai envie de contrôler ton plan de
tout à l'heure avec le roi qui avance
donc tour C1 roi B5 A3 ou alors A4
directement c'était les deux les deux
plans ouais et A3 bon ça a l'air ça a
l'air assez confort avec les Blancs je
j'attends je ro B5 à3 et j'attends ouais
pas a pas grand chose à faire peut-être
juste on s'ennuie tous les deux
c'estàdire que je fais tour C
tour est-ce que alorsens
pour est quand
Mme
B5 le RO en B5 il y a comme thème pour
rentrer faut faire
tour rapidement est-ce qu'il un petit
coup il a peur avec les noirs de
s'engager dans quelque chose avec le
manque de temps bon a blanc tourage 2
c'est logique 4 elle veut je pense
qu'elle joue pour le G elle ve gagner ou
elle a eu quand même un peu de réussite
que que
joue roi B6 pour qu'elle joue pour
gagner je pense que maintenant il a
toujours le thème B5 qui peut être un
thème
pour
elle ve plus est-ce qu'elle veut pas c
oui c'est ça c'est intéressant j'aime
beaucoup ton idée parce que là en
pourrait commencer àê mal de l'autre
côté que C5 je peux ne pas toucher mais
il y aura C4 un jour aussi peut-être a
elle joue
passif qu'elle voit pas arriver le la
consolidation alors qu'elle avait la
main ouais elle est en train de perdre
la main là stou sur ça gag un P sur
tour coup elle vient de Ger en fait elle
devait trouver le contrejeu ouais elle a
complètement attendu avec ces domage
parce qu'elle a fait une jolie partie
elle a là elle a joué passif et là elle
a compris qu'elle devait jouer actif
mais c'est trop tard et c'est pas très
actif ce qu'elle a fait finalement B5
c'est un pseudo actif puisque on on pas
de profit change un placeelle va réussir
à annuler c'est incroyable comme ça peut
changer ouais is c'est ouf et encore une
fois là la la la confiance peut être
regagnée chez IFAN après cette victoire
si elle si elle gag F3 bien jou TR le
ro3 en pous5 et ça a l'air d'être elle
va essayer d'harceler le pion e mais ça
suffira pas est-ce que tu penses qu'elle
va essayer aussi de de VI de pour
empêcher tour F qui peut-être aussi éta
c'est un peu long quand même elle se met
derrière son pion regarde comme c'est
bien joué très
mécanique tuaimes pas le tour échec pris
C5
peut-êre prend3 le pion d c'est dur là
elle a plusieurs finales à choisir d
prend C5 et tour G3 ça ça a l'air normal
G5 j'avais peur que ce P soit pas faible
un jour T4 quand même qui vient qui
vient défendre ce pion bien je viens
ici4 t F5 peut-être tour G4 d'accord
c'est bien aussi parce que
maintenant dans ce match dans cette
partie
surtout costuk je vais vous remettre les
points à jour ouais là il faut repartir
donc cette dernière partie he
de 5 +
1 c'est la dernière il reste 40 secondes
c'est la dernière partie de ce
euh cette portion donc 3 et demi 3 et
demi pour l'instant dans ce match en 5 +
1 et tout à l'heure moi je t'avais dit
je pense hein je je pense franchement
que que cette cadence qui est un peu
plus lente favorise quand même au final
IFAN et je pense que dans les cadence
plus rapide costenuk peut euh en tout
cas se met un peu le trouble alors bien
sûr IFAN reste je sais pas sou en fait à
chaque fois que je commence à avoir une
CER certitude dans ce
match c'est c'est un petit peu l'inverse
de ce que je pense qui se produit par
exemple je voyais bien queostenuk
l'emporé dans la partie précédente je
trouvais qu'elle elle assurait bien et
la finale est passé à côté euh il y a de
très très bonnes choses dans dans ces
matchs mais il y a aussi des moments de
flottement
IFAN c'est pareil j'ai trouvé vraiment
hyper forte dans certaines phases de jeu
mais elle a aussi fait des grosses
gaffes aujourd'hui il y en a deux trois
qu'on peut citer
donc en fait fan si elle ne gaffait pas
bah ça irait mais elle a fait deux gaffe
et ça lui a coûté deux points quoi
ouais donc tout dépend de on voit
qu'elle voit très vite tout ça mais il y
a quelques moment de de gros flottement
c'est plus des flottements c'est des
trous bon par contre c'est pas si bien
passé pour les blancs là qui n'ont pas
obtenu grandchose de P isolé en terme
d'activité on en voudrait un peu plus
ou D6
j regardez déjà au niveau
de de son body language là
c'est on sent qu'elle est pas contente
de de son
ouverture elle est en galère elle est en
galère touffe directement tu vois elle a
un peu perdu le fil là avec la perti
perdu elle se rend bien compte que la
finale de tour elle devait jamais la
perdre euh
elle accuse un peu le coup déjà avec sa
sa gestion du temps qui veut dire que
elle a l'impression qu'elle a déconné
complètement son pion isolé ouais et
c'est une sale tronche on on a la jauge
pour nous dire que finalement les blancs
sont à l'équilibre mais c'est vrai que
si on réfléchit humainement la position
la pression dégagée par la dame B6 sur k
B5 pion D4 pion B2 B c'est on a pas les
compensations en plus avec
les avec les pièces
blanches du coup c'est c'est pas
terrible
pas simple qu'est-ce que j'aurais toi
fou
TR fou des3 je sais pas le problème
c'est que arver ça peut être un coup
aussi ouais les A6 et
les les thè comme tu dis
ouais B4 c'est très fort comme tu dis
Souf bah j'ai CAV C7 aussi intéressant
j'ai pas mal de
trucs ça me laisse pas mal de mais
peut-être A6 c'est tranquille en plus
non A6 tranquille peut-être ouais d' pr
B2
ouais pour voir enfin ça fait peur en
tout cas je suis obligé de
calculer réfléchi elle a fait t elle a
réfléchi
elle a réfléchi
une minute plus d'une minute minutes
même 2 minutes réfléch
pourouer 2 minutes quand on a 5 sur un
coup elle connaissait elle se rappelle
plus ou des fois c'est des choses comme
ça
oua al tour8 elle fait des coup viment
très logi avec les Noirs visis là tape
sur le pion isolé
en4 c'est bien ce qu'elle fait 8 après
et puis hop on travaille comme tu
dis comme ça la case D6 on peut pas y
toucher avec les Blancs il a eu fou D3
et là on peut penser à cavali4 parler
tous les coups tour C8 cavalier B4 fou8
on sait juste pas quoi choisir avec les
noir faut jouer assez vite le premier
coup instinctif ou il faut la pressionch
beaucoup 2 minutes sur un coup ça veut
dire qu'elle est vraiment en doute et si
tu arriv à l'enterrer un petit peu en
jouant un petit peu plus vite ça peut
aussi être pas mal on est pas au poker
mais mais la psychologie sa ouais dans
ces cadence rapide il y a il y a cette
dimension là trve comme tu le dis de de
de de mettre la pression et d'être un
peu plus psychologique que dans les
parties lentes aux échacs c'est ça bien
joué cette séquence C des 5 cavalier
des5 ouais cavalier commence à liquider
le jeu plus les pièces mineures sont
échangées plus ça favorise le camp qui
n'a pas le pion isoléou parce que le
camp qui a le pion isolé doit faire la
différence avec les pièces sur les
chiquers moins il aura de pièce plus le
pion isolé sera vulnérable tour de on
sent que elle a perdu le fil dans dans
ce genre de position parce que ça peut
pas être bon mais en même temps elle a
pion B2 en l'air donc elle elle elle
n'est pas contente d'elle on sent que ça
devient un peu frileux ouais peut-être
elle est pas à l'aise avec la C1 et tour
C8 tu en penses quoi c'est logique on
peut jouer simple moi je vais changer
parce que je vais mettre la pression sur
ton pion je veux échanger en fait quand
tu as un pion isolé il faut que tu jouer
actif parce que tu as une faiblesse sur
long terme ici et et si tu arrives pas à
jouer actif et ben tu vas te retrouver
pas bien avec tous tes problèmes donc
j'aimerais bien jouer un5 aussi stou
pour oui ouais oui en plus mon C5 il est
vent très fort il contrôle les casques
C7 euh il y a plus de
problème lae tour C2
ouais mais tour C2i manger faire fou B5
je pourrais plus ouais et puis il y a le
petit truc en ha7 pour Ess de
effectivement ouais il y a un truc
là-haut et puis en plus faire fou B5 bon
même si j'ai raté fou prend H7 B on est
mieux hein G6 G6 fou B5 ça va être pas
mal à un moment
ouais et sur tour tour C2 est-ce que je
peux pas jouer autre chose est-ce que
tour C6 c'est pas si débile il y a eu
dame B1 tiens dame B1 là G6 elle garde
les pièces elle elle connaî hein les les
mécanismes évidemment Alexandra costenou
de ces positions là mais elle subit bah
ses choix précédents puis c'est du des
parties extrêmement rapid donc elle sait
qu'il a eu des petites déconnades
maintenant elle s'accroche avec son pion
isolé
ou et après 5 peut-être 5 ça va un jour
don4 alors ouais elle veut faire cavaler
5 plus tard mais j'a toujs fou
elle vend
F8 de Cal 5 problème sur F7 ouais c'est
pas trop mal F8 c'est aussi peut-être
que le roi se dit
que elle elle a envie d'échanger des
pièces elle se dit qu'elle va réussir et
le roi sera encore mieux placé pour la
finale ça faire ça un jour plus les
pièces séchangent plus la finale est
proche c'est vrai alà on pourrait manger
en C2 et faire foot 6 peut-être h chaque
pièce échangé c'est c'est un c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour pour lesc ouais on
peut peut faire F F6 pour travailler sur
la la case hm hm D4 mais sur fou D6 sur
Caval 5 ah non je prends ouais sur fou
F6 aussi mais il y a il y a le pion ah
oui fou D6 tu as raison il y a cavalier
E5 sur dame prend des 4 K G6 qui est
compliqué
aussi donc fou F6 mais peut-être que je
peux F6 travaille bien fou C6 c'est bien
aussi fou
C6 Caval le 5 là n'est plus possible par
prend des 4 donc maintenant il y a plus
F 6 possible non plus avec noir mais
contre un pion isolé on dit qu'on
préfère échanger les pièces mineures
finalement c'est les la paire de tour
qui a disparu plus une pièce mineure
c'est l'avantage noir mais on a des
espoirs de tenir cette position avec
avec les blancs mais c'est une position
à deux résultats normalement si j'aime
bien c'est sympaass fou D5 peut-être bon
déjà je3 déjà mais là fou D5 va être
peut-être le coup ouais c'est bien fou
D5 c'est le fou B5 de tout à l'heure
enfin l'équivalent voyez elle échange
les pièces mineures enfin franchement
cette partie elle est hyper pédagogique
hein par rapport au au pion isolé c'est
vraiment bien ce qu'elle nous fait fan
on doit échanger les les pièces de la
couleur inverse au fou on veut laisser
juste le fou G3 à l'adversaire le
mauvais
fou donc là comment je continue dame C8
d C8
attention pour le
roi comment je peux empêcher dame C8
gagner c'est c'est dur mais du coup en
plus il y a une menace discrète que je
n'avais pas trop regardé c'est les
dameschèouent de l'autre côté ouut
moi je regardis un coup comme F6 qui
m'avait l'air pas mal fait prendre les C
du cavalier mais c'est à jouer blanche
ouais je sais mais si tu mets ton
blanche il pour jamais as raison sans
doute mais j'ai peur des dames cavalier
H4 de voir ce que ça donne aussi vite en
faitis je faisais moins de mal mais je
pas fauter quand même mais c'est la
présence du cavalier H4 potentiel qui me
fait peur dame D8 c'est un bon coup
j'aime bien ce qu'elle a fait on on
garde
sereinement
l'au roi G8 peut-être tant pis on met
pas le roi F8 comme ça on est plus on
est peinard avec le thème
elle t'écoute je crois qu'elle a son
elle a ses écouteurs ouais
ouais tout est bon tout est bon non mais
maintenant par contre malgré tout stouf
j'ai proposé ça mais je sais plus
comment progresser avec les Noirs estce
a pas mal de piè
échang des7 c'est pas mal quand même
pour
essayer le le le ouais elle a pas eu
envie de donner son fou cavalier B6 on
navigue elle peut naviguer comme ça
pendant longtemps ouais elle doit poser
des petits problèmes pour jouer le temps
en même temps parce que ah oui c'est
vrai qu'il y a une belle avance temps
quand même de résultat F6 maintenant
Souf oh là là ou elle a raté F6 F6
cétait autre chose he F6 prend des 4
ouais ça
gag bizarre mais bon c'est la pression
du temps hein elle a eu plus de temps
elle s sans doute dit je vais jouer la
finale au temp enfin avec le temps et
peut-être je peux gagner je peux pas
perdre bon elle peut perdre vu le temps
mais vous voyez ce qu'on ce qu'on ve
dire c'est queement elle a très peu de
risque quand même de perdre cette partie
avec les noirs et donc du coup elle se
dit que c'est euh qu'on va se poisser
stouf ça va être bon
ok qu'est-ce qu'on joue là alle un peu
ser serré le roi le roi est revenu on a
peu serré bon j'ai pas de Cass mon fou
pour un mon roi quoi il y a cavalier C5
qui arrive Stouff tu sais qu' a un
problème hm hm
et qui pourrait nous poisser totalement
ouais d'ailleurs elle laaraî hein
G5 est-ce que tu de faire F5 derrière
ouais F5 Onir manger ce cavalier avec
notre et ça y est qu' S5 arrivé prend
c'est intéressant là mais le cavalier en
C6 c'est je contre le fou mais
attention
cavalier c'est l'idée et est-ce que 5 5
roi des 5 encore ouais 5 roi des D5 si
j'arrive à jouer E5 ça va ouais elle
veut gagner hein elle fait roi E5 roi D7
probablement roi F6 elle prend des
risques ultimes elle prend des très gros
risques hein elle s'est fait fixer elle
va perdre elle va finir par la perdre
j'ai mes pions qui avancent là-bas ouais
A4 B5 voilà ça joue vite côté costuk
très propre c'est incroyable parce que
vous vous rappelez du moment où on
disait tout à l'heure qu'il y avait pas
de ris position à deux résultats
maiselle a pris trop là on est sur toute
autre chose on tente
ouais et là il faut juste savoir qu'on
F3 il faut mettre le fou absolument sur
la diagonale là c'est complètement foutu
ouais c'est
foutu va tomber
et elle se laisse même tomber voilà a a
a
a la partie tu vois c'est vous allez
pouir regarder la tête des joueuses là
on en parlait on en parlait de E5 qui
est tu vois si jamais j'ar à faire E5
sans qui roi des5 et ben en fait les
noirs sont très bien parce que je vais
jouer après ro E64 c'est moi qui vais
essayer de pousser ma majorité mais mais
là DS tu fais roi des 5 en fait et ben
moi je pousse ma majorité donc toi tu
pourras plus pousser la tienne parce que
je vais faire un BL avec F3 donc ça
c'est bon il y avait plus de temps à la
pendule mais très très grosse erreur de
d'ouifan dans ouais c'est une gagneuse
he les deux IFAN elle est très
ambitieuse et on voit que
costenou vraiment c'est une gagneuse tu
vois elle était hyper contente après
cette victoire où elle a énormément
souffert elle s'est bien battu elle doit
être quand même cont tente c'est les
deux les deux aspects du joueur d'échec
hein quand on a pas fait une grosse
partie technique faut au moins se battre
sur les chiquel la prouver à Souf oups
oui j'ai mis les points au mauvais
joueur hop donc 4 et demi 3 et demi pour
costenuk dans ce match cette première
partie euh de de match donc on a eu 1
heure écart de 5 plus une et maintenant
on va avoir 50 minutes de 3+ une dans 5
minutes Kevin
ouais tout à fait tout à fait et euh et
ouif elle reste sur les compétitions par
Internet elle est elle est présente hein
oui elle est bah sur Internet elle aime
bien et puis après active je tirais pas
trop non plus hein non non non non non
mais là c'est un tournoi online mais
sinon elle préfère qu Mme les tourno mix
ça c'est clair il a vu d' une histoire
avec à Gibraltar je sais pas si tu tu
avais vu ça une époque à quoi tu fais
pardon à une histoire qui sétait passée
avec Fan à Gibraltar je sais pas si tu
avais suivi non redis-moi je pense que
j'ai vu l'actualité ça me dit quelque
chose mais vu joué alors je sais plus
exactement le ce qui comment c'était
mais elle a joué
euh bon sur peut-être 6 se parties elle
a joué quasiment que contre des femmes
ah oui alors qu'elle elle elle voulait
pas jouer contre les femmes elle a dit
qu'elle voulait jouer ton mi et cetera
et chaque partie
encore une femme tout le temps et
tellement qu'elle a tilté et et au bout
de je sais plus là peêre à 5 6e d'affilé
et ben elle est arrivé à la partie elle
a fait F3 ro F2 ro G3 et elle a
abandonné
fan
ouais c'est non non je pas et voilà donc
il y a eu une grosse histoire là-dessus
et après d' peut-être même c'est la
dernière partie enfin je sais plus je
sais plus et donc donc voilà c'était
assez bizarre
mais c'était il y a longtemps c'était y
a peut-être 4 5 ans même voir plus je
sais plus c'était longtemps mais euh
donc oui donc son histoire avec le
chèque féminin
fan c'est quand même c'est quelque chose
en tout cas on est quand même content de
l'avoir participer dans tous ces ch
parce que c'est quand même la numéro 1
mondial c'est la plus forte et euh et
puis elle est quand même absente hein de
tous les tournois même même mixte he
enfin j quiment plus d'chec en fait donc
c'est cool de
l'avir faut dire que là la dotation
intéresse forcément pour le le temps que
ça demande ben c'est c'est hyper
important donc elles sont pas là non
plus pour rien ce sont des pros
donc forcément elle a envie de faire ça
ça compète parce qu'elle adore les
échecs et en plus derrière il y a un
gros billet pour elle à prendre
ouais ok Kevin on va faire une petite
pause de 3 minutes j'ai un petit truc à
faire technique etattendis la pause pour
ça je vous dis à tout de suite on met
une petite 3+ 1 petite pub on aura 50
minutes de 3 + 1 derrière la pause voilà
à tout de suite tout de
[Musique]
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin pour
cette nouvelle portion en 3+ 1 qui a
commencé d' ça va être bien plus speed
ça vient de commencer et on a cette
structure figée mais avec petit avantage
blanc on va pouvoir faire A4 et
travailler au centre et sur l' dame
ouais d'ailleurs on a déjà eu cette
cette position dans des dans les parties
précédentes en 5+ une donc ça répète un
petit peu et
[Musique]
ouais c la première partie que ça avait
fait nul
d'ailleurs mais c'est plus facile à
jouer côté blanc parce que la pression
les pièces sont bien fichul pion E5 il
est toujours difficile à tenir on peut
avoir le thème F4 F5 et on peut avoir le
thème A4 alors C5 a été joué donc je met
l'idée sou C4 voir même C3 essayer de de
pousser un peu les pièces et C5 a été
joué alors j'aime beaucoup ce coup C5
qui peut paraître bien pas bien d'un
côté tu vois regarde ici ça peut nous
donner la case D4 pour un cavalier qui
pourrait à revenir cette case
là prise cavalier prend et là je dis si
tu obligé à donner la paire de fou j'ai
la paire de fou voilà j'ai pas cavalier
B8 ks6 le plan qui serait indiqué à
cause du pion E5 ouais ça c'est
problématique bien jouéidé cavali8 c'est
l'idée hein tout à fait et et moi
j'aimerais bien aussi mettre un Caval en
des5 peut-être ça pourrait être une
bonne idée donc c'est vraiment idé euh
comment est-ce qu'on va faire pour
mettre nos pièces ici al F4 c'est aussi
un coup peut-être qu' peut pas c'est ce
que je regardais4 tour 8 ouais et F5
mais j'étais pas sûr
ouais ça paraît parce que l'idé des fr
bon si tu prends j'ai une fourchette
bien sûr c'est clair
et prends peut-être la fourchette
j'empêche cavalier B8 aussi c'est
surtout ça voilà donc tour 8 ça te
semble-p logique bah c'est la partie F
moi je pens F5 mais F5 on pas s ça me
laisse un peu de temps ouais
oui du coup c'est pas très bon et prise
prise on juste faire ça et petit centre
c'est bien laisseention
ouais j'aime bien ce qu'elle fait
peuttre que je fer F5 un jour mais va
falloir améliorer améliorer encore j'ai
l'amélioration c'est moi qui choisit de
faire F5 donc ça on peut dire si vous es
mettre de la tension des pions vous PZ
attendre ou
c'est le lux
d'attendrere maintenant F5 prend son
sens parce que j'empêche cas 6 voilà là
c'est bien voilà bah tu vois je trouve
c'est c'est très bien là on a vraiment
vu ce qui était la maîtrise de la
tension avec l'envie de faire F5 mais on
le joue pas on attend et on le jouera
dans des conditions encore plus
favorblci on peut essayer de faire H4 ah
oui là là on a envie d'y aller H4 G4 G5
voilà là on passe dans une idée un peu
attaqueest indienne avec elle va
l'envoyer d'ailleurs elle se prépare à
cela ouais probablement il y a aussi
tour D1 qui peut être aussi un coup
intéressant et cavalier G4 cavalier E3
tu sais pour nous aussi alors il y a F6
mais elle va re la première aussi ça
voilà c'est ça pas mal elle a réussi à
arriver en premier j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'elle a fait dans cette partie en tout
cas ouifan ouan qui qui qui est mené he
dans ce matchin qui est mené d'un point
et on va voir un petit peu si elle me
fait mentir parce que j'avais dit que
dans les cadences un peu plus rapides
elle pouvait peut-être oh elle a laissé
F6 j'avis 6 H5 ah cétait la pointe ok
ouais ouais laisser le le F6 F6
j'auraisement fait t F6 il y avait un
sacrifice à faire peut-être et
maintenant exactement oui oui à tempo je
peux le Remer rapidement sur H5 cavalier
E3 si cavalier prend F6 parour prend F6
le roi il est complètement ouvert et là
ça a l'air complètement écrasant toutes
les pièces qui arrivent donc on est ici
et là ramener une dame là ce serait
parfait mais j'ai quand même toujours
fou F8 donc c'est pas encore si simple
non non il va travailler on a les
histoires de F mais c'est
pasett H4
pourettre plus ave h peux
jourett je
prendsention bouge pas trop plus de
temps ça un moment déjà un
peu
important là
pour4 faut essayer de balancer
G4 D6 de joue non plus de temps T4 H4
peut-être tuas pas trop envie d'ouvrir
la colonage quand même ni la colon
noir comment on passe avec les Blancs
c'est sûr qu'on est mieux mais qu
liquide avec tour B8 doit se poser les
questions
norm pièce noir qui qui mar un peu
dessus et les jours on préfère jouer
avec les blancs mais clair est-ce
que B7 est une idée ah déjà poissé avec
dans les pions isolés ok alors il y a eu
mon plan avec FO H4 FO H3 très bien
ouais pe en
J ouis tour F pas trop deentrée che chez
les noirs et G4 maintenant allez hop G 4
prise F prend et on ah ça fait ça met la
PR là ouais il a peu de
tempson pas jouer peut pas rentrer a
avance là peut-être fois 6 pour tenter
mais bon là c'est ah bien joué dame
G1 dame G1 tourbé c'est pas mal
ouais ça faisait échec et pr la petite
tactique la petite tactique
chcom allez h are tactique à la suivante
donc du coup qui égalise dans ce match
et Alexandra qui joue cette variante
très moderne de la vente d'échange pas
de prise de tête etan qui répète P isolé
est-ce qu'elle va répéter le tour 8 de
tout à l'heure jeense pas plus ouis peu
différent différ tout à
l'heure très agréable pour les blancs
c'est un bon choix de la part
d'Alexandra
aucun risque ou c'est ça c'est une
position simple fou6 et B4 B5 peut-être
on peut jouer différemment de C4 B4 B5
c'est c'est thématique allez cavalier 5
a été joué sur Caval pr tu prends quoi
du P du pion D4
ouais les deux sont jouables à vrai dire
mais bon si on fait K5 c'est pas pour
reprendre la tour à cause de fou D6
mais l're cavalier va peut-être cavalier
F3 il cavalier ouais c'est ça un peuon
non je préférais B4 tout à l'heure il y
aurait peut-être eu A6 mais on passe par
cavalier B3 après il y a cavalier E4
aussi à surveiller mais h ou alors là on
peut jouer fo3 peut-être comme tout à
l'heure 3 j'aime bien l'idée pour
essayer d'échanger les fou de case noir
avir cavalier E4 et C4
vis peut-être je sais pas c'est
compliqué déjà ouis C4 c'est quand même
chaud comme décision à prendre et du f
B4 il y a des trucs sur le plan de 4
aussi mais cavalier com cavalier E4 en
l'air bon c'est la
pour 3 non c'est la partie ou ouais j'ai
cru que je l'avais lâché mais c'est
c'est l'ordinateur qui l'a joué
cavalier prend C6 C4 ça peut être
chouable aussi bon après je peux aussi
faire dame dame de TR tranquille hein et
puis bien sûr c'est peut-être le le plus
on sait qu'elle a joué le coup concret
ouais bon et là sur pion prend il y a
de4 qui peut poser problèm ouais
cavalier prend c'est logique pour
continuer un petit peu dans la même dans
le même état d'esprit ouais
et sur fou B4
tour3 ça l'air logique4 tour3 et euh et
comence garde la pression au moins sur
le cavalier E4 quoi ouais
elle a pris du pion tiens et après fou
B4 en plus il un problème problème tac
ici je sais pas où la mre ma tour
voilme comme
ça
temp pourfendre et après prisee son pas
mal fait complètement avir une super
partie ce qui est frustrant pvez faire
une très bonne partie stratégique en une
décision balancer tout à la poubelle
c'est ce qui s passé parce que
maintenant le pion a
bah c'est presque un pion de moins cette
position parce que la majorité du pion
E5 F2 G2 H2 cont le le 4 contre 3 de
l'elroi ben il est pas très impactant et
à l' dame on prend l'eau il y aura A5 il
a le travail sur C4 bon c'est la la kata
ouais si je mange C4 de P passé li et le
pion c'est s rien faire hein elle a pogé
là sur une séquence et oua et c'est pas
facile hein parce qu'il y a la pression
du temps et dans les petites décisions
stratégiquesan elle va
vite très très vite il faut que Cuk
arrive à l'attirer dans les dans des
parties moins
ouais moins stratégique plutôt dans les
parties Bordell on a vu que dans le
bordel était bien
tiré donc le bordel c'est vraiment les
parti d'attaque partie complexe dans les
position stratégi là elle fait une
Master Class avec les noir depuis le
début de la partie elle a tout compris
et ça fait quand Mme de parties elle a
quand même beaucoup de temps d'avance à
la
pendule est rapide et elle met la
pression l'impressionant non mais si
elle fait pas de grosses conneries c'est
terminado même depuis le début du match
finalement elle a filé quand même deux
parties sur deux grosses bvu mais
estandme aessus dans le niveau de je
ouais ouais ouais mais d'ailleurs elle
se défend bien c parce que je pensais
qu'à un moment elle sombrer elle est
revenue à chaque fois elle se bat mental
ouais même dans le pion isolé qu'elle
avit mal maîtrisé ben elle s'est battu
elle a réussi juste avant la
pause tour C7
ok bon là
Clement moins palpitante parce que les
les noirs doivent envoyer les pions et
gagner mais une erreur est toujours
possible elle doit faire des petites
choses pour mettre un peu de voilà comme
cavalier F4 très bien on attaque le pion
E6 on dit qu'on va faire des fourchettes
on fait une cavalcade sououff non mais
j'ai du Fou B6 j'ai des choses à
regarder hein c'est pas voilà c'est ça
c'est c'est en fait on sait qu'on est
gagnant mais l'autre peut nous embêter
regardez cavalier des TR la cavale 4
continue
5 on prendre la tourz vite hein tour
prend cavalier prend a prend et puis
voilà elle regarde les structures les
deux les deux sont en temp et ça y est
elle va rejoindre au temps avec le la
peur de gagner un petit peu dans ces
positions là ouais elle veut elle veut
juste sur cavaler pr c'est à prend tu
vas devir faire parce que cavalier prend
je prend à 5 mais elle ve juste être
s'assurer de faire les bons coups
et puis on prendon c'est doublé mais bon
c'est passé quoi en plus c'est stable le
cavalier il est là donc on va monter le
roiener activer les tours et tour C2 ici
est pas mal du tout ça empêche le roi de
s'activer via
via2 bon là normalement ça devrait le
faire
il y a une fourchette quand même donc
peut-être que tu as pas besoin de de
faire tour à 2 Caval C3 en cas de bien
joué ça et là je toujours attendre parce
que prise tour B6 encore B6 et je peux
pas jouer R7 petite galère ouais ça fait
écha le roi arrive mais bon j'aurai B5
pour donc roi E7 roi D6 déjà on va
ramener le roi ouais et sur roi C4 euh
peut-être roi ici
ouais c'était bizarre de laisser roi C4
et de pas B5 soême ou5ention4
pour quand
même 20 secondes ça va vite qu'est-ce
qu'on
joue ouais je peux me
replacer je très très bien c'estd
qu' les no de bout en bout faut
Pasquer ça y est
en
ok ch on fait le
tour ce pion qui va être perdu mais j'ai
mon cavalier qui va arriver en
ouais c'est cl me laisse AC mon roi tour
C34 à tour B3 c'est très bien aussi tour
C3 c'était mieux sans doute peut-êtreait
qui pouvit être des Arabes ouais là là
en train
de parce que les menaces vont être
importantes avec tour de roi B3 et
cavalier C4 ouais là c'est
ça ferme le réseau
se
bat pe pas faire tour perduant non
incroyable tu vois comme c'est
terrible mais de ou c'est pour ça que
je'avais dit que je pensais dans Caden
très très
rapid pouvait peut-être un peu faire la
[Musique]
différence
plus je vois pas le
temps alors donc on va on va changer un
petit peu ses scores
ouais oui elle va il va falloir qu'elle
elle stabilise ah oui F a joué une
variante avec de P3 k D3
entre un petit peu Carlsen où on échange
les
dames bon c'est peti avantage petit
avantage blanc et on a dit que
stratégiquement fan elle jouait très
vite c'est vraiment dans la conclusion
pour l'instant que Wian elle elle
déconne c'estàdire qu' elle est
extrêmement rapide Stouff avant et d'un
coup elle se crispe un peu et dès
qu'elle se crispe elle est un petit peu
plus
lente mais bon c'est dur évidemment
cette cadence de jeu mais elle pourrait
un peu plus lâcher ses coups et faire
mal sans doute à son adversaire ouais
tout cas bon choix d'ouifan dans ses
structures elle a montré que les parties
plates étaient en sa faveur quand même
is même sil nait pas toujours réussi à
faire les
différences c'est marrant a joué D5 ici
qui paraît un petit peu anti
positionitionnel peut-être pour MRE le
cavalier en D4 ouais c'est sûrement
l'idée prendre de l'espace avec C4 un
jour4 bon c'est plus agréable pour les
blancs mais bon comme les dames sont
échangé l'espace un peu moins important
H4 très joli veut l'espace partout sur
les chiquers c'est vrai que les pièces
particulement les cavaliers
blancs font un beau bloc
et ça me paraissa bizarre mais ambition
ouais par que tu prends tu changes la
structure et tu arrives un petit peu à
jouer avec tu es fou si la sou es fou
pour pousser les cavaliers avec du RE C5
c'est ça cavalier B57 B5 un coup un coup
à regarder c'est une
fin H4 enfin j'arrive à en tout cas
costenuk inspiré dans ce début de partie
ce qu'elle a pas toujours montré dans
les débuts de partie mais elle est très
inspiré et elle joue vite ouais elle
joue vite mais tu vois c'est encore une
fois la confiance he là tu as un point
d'avance euh tu joues plus
vite il reste 31 minutes dans ce dans ce
7 de 3+ 1 on est quasiment à la moitié
déjà alors fout des deux et la partie on
va pas donner le fou bien
évidemment en tout cas le le format de
ce speed chest me paraît pour les
joueurs plus digeste c'est un petit peu
ce qu'on avait dit alors nous on était
pas joueur Souf mais on le trouvait un
peu
indigeste là j'ai l'impression que le
format est vraiment parfait non
qu'est-ce que tu en penses bah le format
est indigeste quand le niveau est est
trop trop différenci différentah il y
avait eu un match que je pense beaucoup
de monde peut-être souviendra c'était le
match de Nakamura contre
IFAN
justement le score final ça avait alors
je sais plus le score final exact
peut-être sur Google les gens dans le
chat vous pourrez regarder mais ça été
un truc du style 212 un truc comme ça
ouais c'est cher 212 alors Nakamura
c'est le meilleur joueur online avec
Caren en blit c'est une c'est c'est un
por quoi enfin est trop fort ou oui
c'est trop dur et et puisan bon bah
c'est la Numéro 1 un mondial bon après
elle était un petit peu hors jeu elle
jou beaucoup moins en éche qu'avant puis
online non plus et puis bon elle a quand
même 2650o et puis Nakamura en blitz sur
internet c'est pas 200780 c'est
il fa il fait des belles cavalcades ah
ouais il est il est monstrueux he
vraiment monstrueux et le score c'était
212 je crois un truc comme ça ouais
heureusement qu' c'est de points ouais
mais tu te dis mais en fait bant battant
enfin tu tu fais 1 heure de 1h30 cétait
1h30 de de 5 + 1 bah en fait c'est bon
on arrête quo enfin il y avait déjà je
sais plus comment c'étaitre c'éit genre
un truc du sty 91 quoiin 91 au boutun
heure de jeu stop enfin ça sert à rien
tu
vois et puis après il y avait aussi un
débat par rapport au format est-ce queon
pouvait faire en terme de 7 regarde ah
ou ou oui je vois ce que tu veux dire
oui oui estce que gag tu mets 91 bah ok
tu as gagné le premier set mais après le
2e set je peux me remotiver pour essayer
de gagner prends après 9-1 bah c'est
fini euh je sais dans ma tête c'est
perdu quoi le match il signé ouis bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr et euh et tu vois
au tennis prend 6-0 6-0 6-0 bah tu peux
revenir quoi hein ououais tout à fait
tout à fait et c'est l'idée en fait et
donc bon après c'est voilà dans ce match
là comme tu le dis là le niveau quand
même on voit les parties enfin le score
et tout c'est quand même assez serré
hein donc ça va celui-là oui oui oui
mais le format peut être des fois
difficile euh mais en car c'était très
déséquilibré ouais
oui oui oui bon après les car souvent
bon même même chez les mix hein euh car
souvent c'est quand même un peu
déséquilibré c'est souvent les les demi
quand tu vois des des nakaso ou des ou
des firou Carlsen ou des mvl tu vois là
c'est c'est clairement chaud quoi mais
généralement vers les carart c'est quand
même normalement il y a pas trop trop de
surprise quoi
là c'est chaleur là pour pouran qui
s'est trompé dans les complications elle
se retrouve avec deux pièces attaqué St
et
termin 15
secondesise si elle Perette partie sera
Mo dans le match et
gr grosse partie de C à nouveau
elle sera moin là elle va pas laisser
échapper je pense elle en avance autant
pour l'instant dès qu'elle été avance
autant elle a elle a serré la
vis je la vois pas dans cette position
clean s'incliner elle va mettre les
pièces sur les bonnes cases pon pour
elle on doit être concentré le fou E3
attaquer la case D6 aussi fou C5 puis
autant elle a même beaucoup de temps
d'avanceanou faut juste pas se crisper
en fait dans ces positions là fou G7 on
se replace en enfin fou F8 en G7 ouais
faudra faire attention à K D6 voilà
c'est ça le truc voilà H6 déjà pour se
donner de l'air ouais il a ça en l'air
aussi plus tard on prend et maintenant
là on a plus de de menace de math ouais
il y a plus rien du tout il y a plus
trop d'échec il toujours cette case là
pour le roi et abandon même peutêre
tomber tomber ouais tomber aïe aïe aïe
ça commence à être dur pour yfan bon bon
ben tu nous avais annoncé ça il y a
quand même là dans le dans le 3 + 1 un
petit de a qui vient de se dérouler
c'est ça et donc on est maintenant à 6
et demi 4 et demi avec un un plus 2
alors je sais pas s'il y aura une pause
après ce après cette partie ouais ça
sera la surprise peut-être la pause de
mi-parcours je pense qu'il y en aura une
et mais
bon quand même beaucoup de pause quand
même dans ce ce tournoi parce que
oui les pauses à mi-parcours c'est c'est
ça casse un peu le rythme de mon ça
casse un petit peu et puis bon là ell on
quand même trois parties donc ça fera
une 4è partie enfin ça va je pense ouais
c'est 3 + 1 en plus c'est pas 3 + 1 4
parties tu peux enchaîner hein oui oui
une pause dans le 5+ 1 c'est pas bête
ouais après mais bon de toute façon a il
y a déjà la pause de entre chaque
cadence c'est bien une petite pause
entre chaque cadence trouve que c'est
c'est juste oui non ça ça c'est normal
mais après dans le 5+ 1 pourquoi pas
mais sinon on posuse à chaque fois ça me
pas ça fait beaucoup je trouve plus 2
plus 2
donc salut rout j'espère que tu vas bien
rout tu sais que rout passe bien tu sais
que rot a lancé sa sa sa chaîne de de
stream rot qui stream maintenant sur sa
chaîne les gars si vous voulez aller
voir route streamer n'hésitez
pas on peut lui faire un petit saut
bravo à toi ouais sa route oups attends
je suis en majuscule saut n'hésitez pas
à aller voir en tout cas sa
chaîne hop et d'ailleurs ben nous aussi
on stream enfin toi je sais pas tu
streames encore beaucoup Kevin non pas
pas ces derniers ces derniers temps
parce que ben tu sais fill en basage
j'ai la plateforme de cours en ligne les
vidéos YouTube et l'ensemble fait que
bah je streamerai mais irrégulièrement
voilà le championnat de France par
exemple jeune c'est sûr je le streamis
et et d'autres petits événements mais
non je avec la plateforme en ligne ça me
prend trop de trop de temps ouais
beaucoup beaucoup de travail mais en
tout cas n'hésitez pas quand même à
suivre sa chaîne aussi et moi j'ai fait
une grosse pause aussi mais j'essaie de
revenir plus mais je te dois toujours
dès que tu repasses en stream dois
toujours si subs stou et c'est bien que
je
je je men souvenais même plus mais il
faut que je trouve bah si si moi je sais
tu vois mais il faut que je trouve
trouve le moment pour passer ou alors je
jeallis payer ma dette sans que tu sois
en direct ah c'est plus sympa quand je
suis là quand même bah ouais ce que je
me dis ce que je me dis et pour ceux qui
sont intéressés par la plateforme en
ligne je vous mets le petit cadeau vous
pouvez aller chercher à votre
inscription comme ça vous avez
tout tout ce qu'il faut pour progresser
aux échecs alors parle-nous un petit peu
si tu veux de ta plateforme qu'est-ce
que tu proposes bah tu sais c'est c'est
des pack des packs vidéos sur des des
sujets thématiquesouf le dernier en date
que j'ai sorti le weekend dernier
c'était sur les structures de pion où
j'ai pris l'exemple de la défense
française qui est avec la carocane les
défenses que je trouve les plus facile à
appréhender pour les joueurs amateurs et
qui sont saines dans le temps et là j'ai
pris l'exemple de de la française j'ai
décortiqué toutes les structures de pion
qui existent dans la défense française
sans rentrer dans le détail théorique
c'était vraiment voilà les les réactions
type autour de la structure de pion et
j'ai pris pas mal de plaisir à faire ce
ce pack vidéo il y a il y a 3h et dem 4h
de de vidéo sur ce sujet-là et euh voilà
c'est un pack vidéo j'ai fait les
finales pratiques les finales théoriques
des ouvertures pures avec des systèmes
que je conseille la col zuuker tort euh
donc la carocane comme je l'ai je l'ai
dit gambiam accepté que j'aime beaucoup
aussi sur dcat avec avec les Noirs bref
ce sont plein de pack thématique et
j'indique quand même quel est le niveau
amateur confirmé expert voilà en me
disant que amateur 12 1600 confirm 1600
2000 et plus de 2000 j'appelle ça les
experts voilà voilà Stouff le ouais le
tout tout le sujet mais c'est c'est
super puis par rapport au au au stream
c'est plus mon domaine puisque j'ai
donné des cours depuis toujours enfin
depuis toujours non depis 15 ans voilà
je suis vraiment entraîneur pas streamer
à la base donc là c'est vraiment mon
sujet donc c'est très plaisant à faire
par contre euh ça prend toujours du
temps et comme tu le sais j'ai décidé de
rejouer aux échecs avec la petite
embasage plus ça streamer c'est de
streamer régulièrement c'est c'est plus
dur ouais mais tu le comprends quoi bah
bien sûr tu vois tu vois exactement de
quoi je veux parler bien sûr mais en
tout cas ça fait plaisir et n'hésitez
pas à aller visiter aller visiter sa
plateforme en ligne avec on sur son
stream et cetera
et et et puis voilà et et toi stouf tu
disais que tu as tuas tu as moins
streamé bon il y a aussi la vie perso
les horaires et cetera tu tu compes y
remettre bah je me suis remis depuis
lundi dernier mais mais euh mais j'ai eu
là la visite d'un ami à la maison
pendant 4 jours enfin c'est un peu
compliqué donc quand je peux j'esser de
stream
oui plus tu
chessc ça prend toujours temps voilà
puis j'ai d'autres projets qui arrivent
je vous en parlerai un peu plus tard
mais je pense sur les coups de Noël vous
aurez peut-être des petites surprises on
verra je dis rien pour
l'instant comme ça ça dépend comment ça
avance tu sais des fois ah oui bah des
fois des fois on dit des trucs et final
tu es pas prêt du tout tu te fais avoir
par le temps et ça fait longtemps
d'ailleurs que j'ai ce projet en tête et
que j'arrive jamais à le faire mais là
du coup ça ça commence un petit peu à
euh ouais
puis maintenant que tu as eu ton titre
de Mii c'est peut-être plus facile aussi
de te focaliser sur d'autres éléments
que le le jeu même si tu aimes toujours
ça tu ASAS toujoursoui après je suis ça
fait longtemps quand même que je me
focalise plus trop sur mon jeu quand
même bien sûr HM parce que bon même si
je voulais être amis entre nous
travailler les échecs alors que tu es
rentraînur et tu Stre mais que tu fais
tout ça c'est dur hein tu as le tempend
de rien donc juste vos échecs enfin
c'est dur quoi mais mais bon non juste
plein de projets qui arrive en tout cas
et ça fait plaisir de pouvoir faire
plein de choses différentes oui c'est
hyper vivant comme taf on a de la chance
hein bah ouais puis mainant avec les
échecs qui sont ti il y a eu nul avec
leschec nul et euh
fan s'en sort mais
d'une partie hyper ardue là elle vient
de s'en tirer sinon c'était + 3 on était
proche du + 3 et presque du KO stou je
sais pas ce que tu en penses mais oui
oui oui du coup il y a pas eu il y a pas
eu de pause c'est qu cavaliers fou C4 on
peut jouer ça stouf nous qui disons tout
le temps cavalier prend
E4 alors l'idée c'est qu' fa prend F7
c'est pas une bonne ligne pour les
blancs alors ça a l'air bien de
récupérer la comme ça mais je crois que
D5 ro G8 il me semble avec j'ai
l'imession que IFAN commence à être
tilté et à faire un peu n'importe quoi
sou je suis quand même hyper étonné
ouais et là réflexion si tu veux encore
bon on peut jouer ça on peut tout jouer
en blitz et prend le 4 réflexion bon on
connait normal la suite c'est cavalier
prend E4 D5 fou D3 de4 fou E4 tout ce
qui arrive fou D6 fou D6 avantage noir
plus ou moins
quoi c'est marrant qu'elle joue ça parce
que normalement on dit que c'est un
petit peu interdit ouais que le problème
c'est rock F5 quoi enfin ça va arriver
vite mais c'est plusieurs fois qu'elle
fait des
[Musique]
trucs pas trop trop tu elle joue pas
théorique il y a plein elle joue plein
de trucs un peu pas théoriqu ou ouais je
comprends bon là c'est pas une énorme
surprise puis c'est une énorme surprise
alors tu sais quand tu joues ça sauf tu
serais pas le dernier à jouer un truc
comme ça peut-être un peu bordur mais en
mettant la pression au
temps là là elle a 2 10 contre 2 45 je
vois pas trop
l'histoire
clairement clairement d'ailleurs j'ai
j'ai une scène on peut vous montrer un
petit peu si vous
voulez je sais pas si c'est mis à jour
on va essayer vous voyez
les regarde tu
vois donc current prediction ça veut
dire c'est la prédiction de la partie
qui est en direct sur le pourcentage de
bon coup tu vois 30 % Dean contre 70 al
je l'ai pas à l'écran ah non pardon non
non non non non je dis n'importe quoi là
c'est non ça c'est sur le score du match
non non je dis n'importe quoi en fait
chcom ajuste ah oui d'accord chesscom
ajuste tout ça bien sûr je comprends non
mais c'est bien c'est onerel si vous
voulez on va laisser celuilà elle est
complètement tiltée depuis un moment et
d'ailleurs on a vu qu'à un moment elle
est elle avait atteint des sommets
puisqueelle était quasiment elle était
archi pénard dans son match ouais et euh
et du coup elle a elle a craqué elle a
craqué véritablement au moment où elle
allait vraiment prendre une avance
considérable c'est vrai que c'est sympa
ces petites prédiction j'aime bien moi
Stouff et euh
ouais bah c'est super sympa c'est rigolo
c'est dans l'air du temps la costtigou
qui a fait une manœuvre qu'elle doit pas
trop apprécier elle-même avec sa dam
achète elle s'est un peu pris les pieds
dans le tapis ouais là c'est qu' une
partie très vite la CAD pour pouran ici
elle a elle est à Mo- 2 elle a les
blancs il faut marquer hein il faut
marquer ouais k C4 peut-être mettre la
pression sur le
sur5 peut être pas mal
elle avait bien joué
elle s'est
embourbé avec sa sortie de dame mais bon
la position vous voyez que les temps 12
20 une58 il peut tout se passer on l'a
bien vu tout à l'heure qu'on vous
annoncit que c'est une position à deux
résultats avec un pion isolé très bien
mené c'est d'ailleurs le tournant du
match cette position du pion is que IFAN
a finalement bah
perdu c'est quand même le tournant j'ai
l'impression de de ce match de de speed
chass pour le moment en tout cas
jusqu'au prochain retournement s'il y en
a un et que
ouifan arrive à revenir dans le match
pour l'instant canuk lui pose d'énormes
problèmes ça c'estz marrant ce qu'elle a
fait damage 7 c'est même plus un fieto
ça c'est ouais c'est c'est un truc c'est
le néo fiketto ouais mais c'est
intéressant même E4 parce que prise tour
6 ok j'aurais pu tour 6 pour essayer
d'aller manger bon on va le faire tour 6
tour 6 sette d ouais elle est en train
de de cogiter autour de5 mais il va
peut-être falloir le faire pour fermer
le fou B2 ouais feres le fou tuouv le
fou B7 et il va pas avoir envie de trop
le faire
peut-être bah c'est ça où je perds le
pin4 ou je sais pas mais je pense qu'il
faut je 5 ça m'a l'air assez envie elle
a 5 50 secondes wou ok de tant pis elle
dit la damchette est bizarre ouais mais
je prends tout maintenant reprends
est-ce que j'ai sur prendre pr une
petite ça pas mal
je pour1 je mets mon ro H2 peut-être
c'est ça qu'elle veut jouer je sais pas
elle l' pas anticipé en tout cas sans
doute parce que ça va très vite ouais
mais c'est quand même assez bizarre je
pense il est quand même très fort ici le
le mien j'ai moins de possibilités parce
que tu vois que j'ai j'ai pas de C pour
attaquer ce pion G7 avec les Blancs
alors que les Noirs ils ont quand même
je trouve hein son qui plus facile va
faire dame G4 pour essayer de faire la
finale ouais cétait c'est pas mal en
pratique quand même parce que elle peut
gagner quand même ouais même si c'est
sans doute nul fot couleur opposé il y a
les tours et la structure défaillante
ouais il y avait des sur son roi bien
joué bonne décision pratique je pense
mais il faut faire attention faire
attention au temps parce que tout à
l'heure elle a quand même perdu
plusieurs fois au temps tout à fait
fan et là elle a 3 enfin 30 secondes
contre 50 et il faut vraiment qu'elle
arrive à plus vite on peut faire F3
mettre le roi en F2 jouer fois pour fois
3 peut-être qu'il faut faire C4 pour pas
se prendre C4 elle a pas fait C4 donc
c'est les noirs qui doivent faire
C4 C4 c'est un peu un problème je pense
ah il fallait faire C4 a a a trouvé
maintenant ont raté puis trouvé ouais on
donne le pion pour affaiblir les P faut
prendre il faut prendre elle a pas pris
ouais bon
il après elle peut toujours mettre la
pression un pe tout à fait mais elle
pouvit jouer la même position avec un de
plus ouis et là l'IDE de C4
intéressant C4 i pour faire la
fin moyen de de mettre la pression alors
on rappelle que les les les jeunes femes
des choses parce que la cadence est
impossible si vous voulez très vite on
voit des choses parce que on est posé et
elle doiv à chaque fois jouer un coup
pendant nous on est tranquille on s'y
flotte faire attention à cette fixation
des pions de l'ILERI pour pas avoir un
moment un
problème faudrait pas perdre le pion
attention sais P il est pas facile à à
tenir quand même ou c'est clair et ça
peut tu F ouais fou là roi là C4 V et
puis benah mon roi il avance
ou
peut-être regarde ro qui arrive elle
avait envie de faire liid avec C5 ro B7
qui arrive hein B ro B6 elle peut elle
peut
ok B5 B4 elle pousse le pion
hein bah B5 en fait elle va je pense
qu'elle va pousser l'autre B5 B6 B7 ah
bah là elle a joué elle a joué roi D8
donc c'est un petit peu différent
on est complètement F en fait
ou et
maintenant bien jou ai pas mal7 fou D5
peut-être de
revenirain comm tu disis ok j'ai pris
celu déjà ok doit êre FLE Alexandra
parce qu'elle vient de se faire rouler
dans couleuros sait mais ave la pression
du temps bon ch pratique je trouve
d'ifan mais c'est inespéré parce que
elle était
proche proche finalement de la
correctionnelle on peut le dire oui dans
l'ouverture biz do rester on va dire
deux parties
ou encore de parties ou et là il y a que
un point d'écart encore une fois très
serré c'est très serré dans ce match qui
doit essayer de
revenir donc il reste deux parties on va
dire il reste à peu près de 3 + 1 et
après il y aura 25 minutes de 1+ 1 pour
départager ces
dames6 G4 on est dans une variante
marginale de la win hour ouais on ro pas
et B on pe on peut toujours roquer à
tout moment avec les blancs mais prise
est-ce que la foupran c'est pas un coup
si si on on peut bien sûr et il faudra
peut-être alors fout de des de j'aime
beaucoup parce que ça stabilise on
stabilise le centre pour un jour faire
F5 dans de bonnes conditions et le fou
des de peut aider
ouais c'est la PR tu un peu bloqué che
noir tuar pas sais pas trop où mettre
mon roi quand même
ouais B l' mis
là intéressant le concept moi j'aurais
mangé je pense j'auris mangé du Fou
ouais maintenant les blancs F
facilement 3
bien merci à toi qui nous voit sur sur
Youtube euh pour ceux qui sont sur
Youtube n'hésitez pas vraiment n'hésitez
pas à nous à vous abonner sur la chaîne
he c'est gratuit et puis vous serez au
courant de tout ce qu'on
fait en terme de vidéo de live à chaque
fois hein donc n'hésitez pas à à nous
suivre sur Youtube et aussi bien sûr
pour ceux qui sont sur twitch n'hésitez
pas aussi à
à à nous
follow donc dame des7
faile
pour ça me paraît pas une faute B3 mais
ro B2 ça a l'air ass assez assez
classique quand même en tout cas c'est
une belle galère de jouer cette position
avec les Noirs ok tour C7 tour C8 ouais
on va on
va on va gigoter
quoi cavalier à 5 l'autre cavalier ben
il y a manœuvrer il y a plein de bon ou
cavalier à 5 la problématique c'est le
l' sur fou prend à 5 c'est quand même en
bêant
j'ai du mal à à trouver un plan quand
mêmeè là cou va peut-être essayer
elle-même de jouer pour A5 à terme ce
qui
est assez rigolo
ouais en fait les blancs m pas P des4
pour garder les pièces noires un petit
peu mal placer que dès que je mange un
cavalier on échange et puis les Noirs
ont plus d'espace directement et du coup
les noirs sont bloqués mais les blancs
aussi nont pas trop trop de chose à
faire est-ce que peut-être un jour comme
tu l' proposé un coup avec F5 toujours 5
en l'air et G5 c'est un peu la même
problématique c'est pas évident à jouer
en plus a pas beaucoup de temps à la
pendule mais toujours cette petite 30 40
secondes d'avance pour pour C dans
chaque partie en
blitz jou plus vite est-ce qu'on peut
jouer justement cavalier prend D4
peut-être c'est ce qu'elle fait cavalier
prend et cavalier revient VI pour C6
alors est-ce qu'on jou un jour pour A5
ou
non on a pas le temps de passer le fou
B4 fou D6 à cause de K6 dommage ça
serait bien mais ça dame D3 revient
prophylaxie
6 c'est
possible et là est-ce que on joue pour
A5 le problème c'est que tour à avec la
fablesse du pion C3 c'est toujours un
petit
peu véritablement casse gueule qui a été
joué il y a
un c'est le coup des que je regardais
pour essayer de de sortir un peu les
pièces et peut-être F6 pour créer le
pion passé h si j'aime bien j'aime bien
ton idée essayer de tout casser on
bouffe
et tu es un expert de ces structur je c
tu as fait un tu as fait un pack sur les
structures de
pion ouais ouais ouais c'était c'était
relié à la défense française on là c'est
plutôt les les structures un peu carocan
mais
euh encore que on peut retrouver ça
française win comme là mais euh on voit
ça aussi cette maîtrise des pions qui
avancent avec H4 H5 plutôt thématique de
la carocane euh avec ce ce ce ce ce type
de structure et ce coup F6 là oui dame4
pour échanger les dames avant de partir
à à la pêche au pion H6 on évite la
bagarre à Dame où les rois sont présents
ouais là ça va être la soumission parce
que j'ai plus de coup ouais j'aime
beaucoup la
position
iciè parti de
je de mieux en mieux dame D8 ah ça donne
pas envie de
prendre tu prends
de jeai presque rejeté dans ma tête
est-ce qu'elle va avir le panage de
prend le fou
F
ris cavalier B4 on essaie
Carter
elle se retrouve un peu dans la
peau du chasser dame H8 ok maintenant
dame F4 pour faire d pr ça semble
logique t
F3 elle ve ouvr le visis entre le roi la
dame ou est là elle est en position de
contreusean comme tout à l'heure
Alexandra dans cette partie si bien mené
par qu' finalement perdu et là fan elle
gigotte est-ce que le 5 ça peut être une
idée attention 30 secondes chacune 37
pour
costenou il faut que
fan joue beaucoup plus vite
elle arrive pas à trouver un coup elle a
bloqué ouis c'est dur c'est dur faut
trouver l'idée oh là là là tour des 8 un
peu par défaut sans doute j'aime bien d'
f4' en parler d'aller manger le pion H6
ça a l'air pas mal oui il faudra c'est
un une des thématiques est-ce qu'on peut
jouer je sais pas5 c'éit son idée tour
G3 ESS d'ouvrir D3 le problème c'est
peut-être C4 elle le fait quand même C4
c'est C perd le cavalier ou C3 C3 elle a
peur c'est normal mais C3 c'est pas mal
ouais dame ach est-ce que je prends H6
ou
pas je vérifie dame 4 quand même dame 4
Ti elle veut vraiment tout contrôler
c'est bien c'est bien ce qu'elle fait
finalement les pionc ils sont bien
présents et quand tu prends h6 il y a il
y aura ça enir à la fin elle fait tour
le 4 c'est 5 et à force de trop vouir
préparer faire attention à ça tropouir
oh là ça se déséquilibre 7 secondes
contre 12 secondes ça se finit un peu en
n'importe quoi cette
partie B4 B4 4 B5 peut-être il y a tout
qui tombe ça va jouer au chrono alle ça
joue vite attention il y a des cavaliers
C4 tour D7 on sait pas qui va gagner
cette parti je peux vous dire que malgré
l'avantage de la jauge
écrasant c'est pas du tout clair comme
position mais j'ai on se replace on voit
que l'avantage il change attention le
roi les rois roi 6 sans doute on est
presque mat d peutêtre dame C4 et
j'enlève cavalier
C4 c'est un pe c'est un peu bizarre je
trouvetion le fout des deux bien joué
attention plein de
visavis de incroyable AE aïe aïe a
a chaud et
é égalisation de de
ouifan ouis incroyable hein on voit que
maintenant ça se joue sur le fil Stouff
ouais et ouifan là elle a elle a pas
rejoué fou C4 est-ce que cé un miscilick
tout à l'heure je sais pas mais c'était
je sais pas si
c'était
vraiment et ouais elle été en en
position aérodynamique Alexandra
costenou mais ça n'a pas suffi euh des
nightight on ne la voyait quasiment plus
elle était à bloc
elle est beaucoup plus démonstratif
queifan qui a une Poker Face mais
eu en tout cas elle fait des ouvertures
un petit peu un petit peu bizarr
IFAN qu' on prend pas fou G4 là
attention hein oh là là là là là quelle
ouverture encore IFAN
euh bon ed peut-être Souf a
glidé je fais F 4 donc KF3 GF ou D7 fou
F3 fou F3 CD K6 revient super c'est un
peu bizarre quand même hein c'est
concept ce qu'elle fait ouais va faire
fou3 F4 mais en même temps elle nous
montre qu'elle a pas besoin d'être mieux
des fois c'est vrai que quand on est
mieux on a envie de garder le contrôle
on réfléchisse plus donc elle joue des
des ouvertures un peu
un peu sale mais au moins se met pas la
pression de l'avantage c'est nouveau
comme concept sou pas la
pravantage ouais il faut faire quelque
chose comme ça parce que pr et un truc
comme ça j'aime bien ce que tu dis il
faut faire quelque chose toute façon sou
sinon on va se retrouver moins bien pour
rien il dame dame 2 ok c'est un coup
fout D6 j'ai D4 aussi encore qui
intéressant tour G1 ah oua
ok elle fait peur elle annonce que
roqueet c'est impossible elle met la
pression avec des bizarreries he ok
vas-y je t'en prie et rock FO H6 ça fait
déjà très peur c'est bizarre com elle
joue mais il y a quand même des idées
hein elle te fait quand même bien douter
hein intéressant ce ce jepr F3 après il
y a une ligne ouaisuse sachant que c'éit
un peu par défaut j'ai l'impression que
c'est ouais mais il y a il y a une ligne
dans les car cavalier avec un G F3 tu
dois sûrement voir de quoi je par ouais
ouais ouais ouais bien sûr et euh avait
qui avait pas mal été été joué par c'est
Maé par Bro et cetera notamment
et et en fait bah l'idée concept c'est
un peu ça quoi mais les connaissants je
suis pas sûr qu'ils soient séduit par
cette partie parce que tu sais ils
aiment bien quand même jouer vraiment
les trucs hyper correct et là oui non
bien sûr mais mais l'idée de tour géant
enfin dans dans dans cette ligne là
c'est intéressant quand même oui tout à
fait tout à fait donc c'est une reprise
de de l'idée mais façon discount quoi
voilà là c'est non c'est plutôt une idée
un peu bistro que nous
propose truc rapide sur petitck j'avais
pas V FO
68 elle va voulait jouer peut-être mais
prend 5 en fait c mon idé marche c'est
possible mais c'est ça doit être risqué
damage 4 attaque les deux fous ou pas ah
oui al ça ça c'est joli he tu me fait
une fourchette fou C6
bc6 et c'est quoi
j'ai F cavalier D5 fou
G5 le bordel ferme la dame
ouis je pens
ID le délire
total s'am
ici on s'amuse mais je crois
coupil on
est sur fe bien blanc écoute bon c'est
chaud hein mais c'est les position en
tout cas elle IFAN je pense qu'elle se
chauffe sur pour le Bullet tu sais à
jouer des une parti un peu incroyable
ouis ou dam ici j'ai roi là mais c'est
trop bien derrière ouais ro roi des deux
roi des deux c'est mignon donc elle
avait peut-être pas tout vu la cabane
mais bon c'est pas sûr que la cabane
soit un bon truc parce que j'ai pas
j'arrive pas à ramener la dame sur case
noire mais je fais ouais elle faisait
roi D2 tour B1 tu sais ou et tour B8
dame G4 enfin tu vois des
trucs donc je pense que elle a été
inspiré IFAN tout cas
là les peêre seul coup non c'est c'est
beau là ce qu'elle ce qu'elle a fait il
y a des trucs de partout les cas noir
sont très affaibl les rois sont
délirant mais j'aime beaucoup les Noirs
quand même là quand même on voit que fan
elle a joué de manière un peu bizarre
mais la partie elle est elle est
rigolote hein ouais c'est pas si faire
C3 peut-être ça peut aller exactement
c'est pas le gars en si fllotant en tout
cas dans cette partie très
créative le fait que
IFAN joue pas très théori tout on les
parties sont vraiment plus sympas oui
non c'est clair ça change des dirait du
random mais peut-être qu'en fait fan
elle est comm comme elle joue beaucoup
beaucoup moins aux échecs qu'avant et
ben peut-être que niveau théorie elle a
un peu à la ramasse elle se plaise et du
coup elle joue aux échecs comme ça et
enfin elle joue un peu sans théorie ou
quoi après je sais pas un second ça
comme à l'heure ça va être la
loterie sachant qu'il y a 77 ouais et et
c'est terminé c'est la dernière partie
hein c'est la dernière partie du du du 7
moi je pensais à à faire tour tour de de
pour faire tour e de tout à l'heure mais
la tour mal' bien il faut prendre la
colonne ouverte si je peux et là je peux
plus la prendre mais j'en ai une autre
la colonne j'ai et ben c'est pas tout
heant on préfère pres que les Blancs
parce que le le roi il est safe6 av t
attention ah il y a tour 2 attention
peut-être dame F3 je reviens finalement
ouaisouais finalement je suis pas
content elle a un peu craqué peut-être
avec ce coup bon là on touche à rien je
peux toujours jouer à 4 mais à 4 ça me
fait un peu peur si une dame arrive en
A2 un jour mais bonant qu'elle arrive ou
c'est bien pour les finales faudrait
échanger les dames peut-être à un moment
si elle réussit ou jouer sur case
blanche est-ce qu'on peut faire C4 qui a
une tronche bizarre est-ce que roi D1
tour c'est pas une bonne idée je pense
changer les pièces ça va aider parce que
ce fou est quand même pas très très bon
mon cavalier pourra dominer le fou en
fin de partie H4 c'est bien
aussi pour éviter tout fou
G5 pas facile à jouer des deux côtés
dame 6 C4 j'aime
bien F oh le le fou qui revient et le
fou qui revient en jeu dame F6 attention
on vient défendre ici
fou est bien
ouais bah tour 2 content ah ouais ou là
là par contre là ça a l'air essaie
d'échanger desam plus vite tour B8 tour
B1 qui peut arriver aussi un jour
attention super dame B6 attention au
mats quand même
a senti les chos deux
c'est chaud cette histoire dam F6 ro D1
peut-être vous voyez là il joue avec le
le rajout c'est extrêmement chaud tour
F1 peut-être F3 F3 parce que H4 c'est
gagné là maintenant il faut convertir
ouais mais maintenant faut pas se faire
arnaquer tu vois le le matériel d'avance
des noir il est ici c'est
tripl je pense plutô P qui
pourrait
fa la tour d'un coup c'est
activé il faut faire le grand
Toure
extrite pour pousser le pion
a tout ça et comment on fait
maintenant surour pr fa là on prend
H2 av tour 2 à la fin qui faisait
enfilade incroable
etbé ça va très vite é assz joli
malheureusement qui n'est pas récompensé
mais elle était gagnante puis perdante
voyez c'est
du H2 il y avait échec là c'est pour ça
qu'elle ne l'a pas fait bien évid on
voit que Alexandra costen qu'elle est
contente de gagner cette partie mais
elle était pas sûr d'elle mais
IFAN se fait vraiment avoir dans
ouais dans ouais sur la fin de jeu mais
on va dire que c'était la même dans la
partie précédente si tu veux je dirais
que elles sont quasiment au même niveau
dans dans ses mononey time ça tourne
dans un sens et dans l'autre maintenant
les ouvertures bizarres de d'ou fan elle
a changé un peu de visage en cours de de
match voyant que la la stratégie de bien
jouer aux échecs Stouff ne fonctionnait
plus elle a commencé à jouer beaucoup
plus crade et à s'amuser ouais c'est pas
mal quand ça se passe mal d'essayer
juste de de prendre du plaisir en jouant
non c'est clair c'est clair mais donc
maintenant on va commencer le Bullet
donc avec un point d'avance pour pour
costenou costenou qui est qui est très
fort en Bullet ça va être très rapide de
toute façon
ouais
donc là on voit encore COS qui est qui
est 62 %
apparemment vainqueur selon
oui oui parce qu'elle a pas réussi à
faire la différence dans les parties
plus lentes 5+ 1 c'était c'était chaud
et finalement bon là ça ça reste très
équilibré mais on a vu quand même
quelques défaites au temp d'an plus
quelques grosses gaffes
euh ni l'une ni l'autre peuvent
maîtriser les éléments quand il le reste
plus de temps mais costenuk qui est un
peu devant sans doute ouais à cause des
des du fait qu'elle tombe autant parce
que là par exemple elle a aucune raison
de perdre sans jouer par rapport au fait
de de comment dirais-je de de résister
dans ces positions là il y avait encore
une partie à jouer c'était chaud pour
les deux joueurs hein h clairement il
aura joué cavalier prend H2 tout pouvait
se passer après elle essaie de pousser
ses pions et puis on voit quoi à cette
vitesse là oui oui tu peux encore faire
ça et exactement tu pousses t pions bon
après je je quand même manger F2 mais ok
bon pas clair enfin pas clair il fallait
la jouer quoi avec quelques secondes à
la pendule c'est un truc qui se joue
complètement bah d'utant plus qu'on a vu
la jauge faire chaud
froid évidemment c'est c'est ultra tendu
mais on a la chance on a un beau match
donc costuk pour l'instant est devant à
la faveur de de sa victoire dans le 5+ 1
et et dans le 3+ 1 ça a été équilibré
mais ça a été beaucoup plus n'importe
quoi dans le sens que la cadence est est
très est très juste pour faire des des
belles parties on a vu des des bribes et
des séquences de très très haut niveau
et par un moment bah ça a été plus
difficile pour pour les deux joueuse
mais c'est un très beau match ouais
salut rippple salut rippple écoute Kevin
on va faire la dernière pause de la
journée ok
euh et puis on se revoit d'ici 5 minutes
pour le OK
le le dernier set he une plus une en 25
minutes voilà je vous dis à tout de
suite super ça va être le plus
spectaculaire à tout de suite et à tout
de
[Musique]
suite
nous sommes de retour pour le Bullet qui
a commencé à l'instant avec un score de
87 c'est chaud c'est chaud coucou à vous
tous restouf on est parti 16 win et là
ça va bastonner il y a plus 1 pour
costenuk ouais légère surprise et
maintenant en 1+ 1 tout peut se passer
on a vu que les les les les deux
joueuses étaient à la fois fortes même
sous pression et qu'en même temps il y
avait quelques absences par moment donc
on a vu que c'était très indécis cette
suite de match ouais en tout cas le
Bullet il va falloir enfin il faut jouer
vite il faut mettre la pression autant
et euh et je sais pas dans C je sais pas
laquelle arrivera à sortir son épingle
moi depuis tout depuis le début je
t'avais dit que costenuk elle est plutôt
forte
danser
dans cadence maintenant qu'elle n'a pas
le choix IFAN on va voir si elle arrive
à poser des problèmes êche d'ame B2 bien
joué hein parce que F A3 cavalier E2
sans doute tourage 3
E2 B5 ok B5 voilà c'est une bonne
embrouille pour l'instant
ouaisoutrect il y a plein d'idées avec
FO à 3 qui peuvent arriver sur les cases
noires
ici qu'elle veut juste jouer B4 en fait
elle veut pas jouer ça joue assez propre
ouais roi F ti on s'enlève du du vis-àis
le roi souvent il va ici c'est son fermé
donc on a le droit de ne pas roquer
vraiment B4 pour B4 B3 mais sur cavaler
prend elle a réussi un petit peu à
ouvrir la position il a ce pion des de
peut-être maintenant que tout est fait
il il f des deux dam à
6 et maintenant comment on continue
alors tour B1 j'aime bien ce coup oui
oui là ça commence à être ok d prend à4
et attention au temps là
fan qui joue quand même très vite ouais
elle joue sans complexe c'est pas mal
aussi comme comme stratégie ou dame pr
C2 d C2 dame prend C2 avec Dame B1 comme
pointe
ouais ça va très très vite hein
attention peut-être est-ce qu'on va
avoir le tour à ch ou par contre elle a
laissé un
coup elle a fait exprès ouis estce que
c'était une bonne idée on VO que les
deux joueus la position est très
déséquilibrée ça peut faire n'importe
quoi k D3 ça fait toujours plaisir ce
genre de coup cavalier F4 attention
pourra avoir un fou à 5 échec et mat
peut-être tour B2 tout de suite on donne
le fou ici ah a la dame qui protégeit ça
va très très vite je dis n'importe quoi
non mais ça ça va très vite de toute
façon pour les deux joueus très vite
tourb roi F4 le roi l'assaut c'est
n'importe quoi mais ça tient ou
raté complètement raté par les deuse ça
fait n'importe quoi il y a plus de temps
ça me rassure de voir que ça fait
n'importe quoi il y a FO 5 le thème FO 5
qui a été raté avec tour C7 gag la dame
ah ouais là c'est là c'est là c'est
c'est vraiment uneute par coup ah Ouette
partie oublié de de calmer le jeu ouais
ouais tu vois les ner tu vois les deux
joueuses là elles ont fait des erreurs
complètement incroyaable il y a eu la
touronnée là-haut il y a eu FO 5até coup
sur coup et donc tu vois franchement
même si c'est la meilleure je du monde
ben on est tours humain quoi plus lè
oua très très va
s'imposerour de plus là c'est
fini et abandon incroyable donc
égalisation avec la manière finalement
on voit que les deux joueuses quand même
trou sont à peu près au même niveau
c'est ça peut être des bêtises
an avit bien mis la pression mais un
moment c'est parti en V il a eu des
grosses grosses fautes donc il y a des
oublis et tu vois que maintenant on voit
que la prédiction en cours et ben de 49
51 don encore statistiquement C
légèrement favorite dans ce
format donc j'étais pas complètement
idot avec mon avec mon petit truc que
j'avais
dit
oui tu veux dire que avec
le apparemmentcom considère que c elle
est pas elle est pas moins forte sur le
papier en blit VO en 5+ 5 mais bon en
même temps c pour l'instant elle s'est
imposé 5+ 1 donc les prédictions des
fois oui non ça bien sûr ça ça veut rien
dire mais mais bon ça montre bien une
chose c'est que c elle est pas derrière
dans ce match elle elle a été elle a été
derrière une seule fois je crois C au
début oui elle avait ben on a failli
assister tu sais un plus 3ifan sur la
fameuse partie là ça a changé tout le
match he puttin j'aimais beaucoup le
prend F5 là Caval prou mais c'est pas
mal ce qu'elle a fait elle a fait un
petit système qu'elle devait connaîtrean
et ça a plutôt bien tourné pour elle
pour jouer vite 55 23 elle a 30 secondes
d'avance à la pendule 4 peut-être avec K
D7 fou D7 x 4 intéressant tu as aussi
petit Rock Tour 1 qui est pas mal m
petit rock F4 qui est pas mal mais FO
met bien ton petit
je vite
[Musique]
j trop propre début maintenant la
pression4
blanche il est très très
fort
calier
d'ord
des5 les cases blanches voilà
jou c'est une menace tour aussi un
coup1 est juste très très bien aussi un
coup prophylactique jouer vite fa jouer
vite des deux côtés j'aime bien aussi
G6 des problèmes sur le pion
G7 même un jour même un fou H6 qui peut
arriver pas de suite
mais dame D5 juste pour embrouiller
peut-être je sais pas
ouais
h hop attention s'est laissé euh
ouais attention attention attention dam
5 dam 3 mais le roi qui va partir
prendre la fuite via D1 E2 à priori il y
a dame D5 dame 5 quand ça va arriver ça
va ça va faire mal et ça y est ça arrive
fou B6 oh là là là là attention dame D8
peut-être
c'est abandon derrière ouais tu perds
tout tu perds tout abandon et c'est
reparti ça va vite
là
minutes minutes avec prise d'avantage
alors qu'est-ce que nous dit la
prédiction après ça St mtenant elle
donne avantage avantage quand même on se
doutait je vais essayer de tuer Laour de
moi mais je sais pas pourquoi Wian elle
perdure là-dedans parce que c'est quand
même pas une super première partie je
trouve mais bon ok elle elle a gagné
elle a envie d'embrouiller
tu prépares un système dans un match ok
ça se passe vraiment pas
bien un moment donné faut changer bon là
c'est du Bullet elle a gagné elle a
gagné a gagne ouais c'est du bull et
puis a toujours un petit peu de vie par
contre jou elle défendu elle a
défendu et petit rock été joué au final
donc tour souent facile de passer ouais
non puis là elle elle est là elle mène
maintenantan elle mène d'un petit
point et donc là c'est la première
demi-finale demain à 17 on sera encore
là pour la deuxè demifinale qui va
affronter
Harik
contre contreno Catarina
voilà et là c'est bien joué ce qu'elle a
fait Alexandra C qu'elle a très vite
compris qu'il fallait donner le pion
ouais pour dur
maintenant4
peut-êtrealier4 peut-être qu'à ce
moment-l il y aura a 5 on verra ouais ah
c'est une belle position quand même ici
pour cavalier C8 on a quand même en
défense ouais et à 5 à 5 et on
reconstruit et le rang à 6 donc c'est
vraiment la française c'est une ligne où
souvent comme c'est fermé et ben on on a
la possibité la possibilité toujours de
pouvoir bouger le roi plein de fois ne
pas roquer alors souvent le rock c'est
obligatoire dans la française c'est
toujours un peu spécial vu que c'est un
jeu assez fermé vous voyez que
sont
là c'est bizarre
Mans bien parce que tout à
l'heure je sur le RO noir et en train de
séteindre tout àit mais bien pour une
fois bon attention il y aura peut-être
du jeu sur le pion B6 à un
moment B5 moi je suis un peu je un peu B
ou ouas raison tu as raison parce que je
joue F4 et puis maintenant je recycle
tout le monde
là5 le roi qui va le roi qui va se
cacher un peu en
C8 tour en
B7
bon elle
attendan elle a position max regarde les
pièces blanches elle ch les idé essayé
de faire un petit truc malin c'est de
mettre les deux tours pour
éviter5 est très bien la seule
problématique c'est qu'elle n plus de
temps et ça va peut-être la
faire c'est bizarre ça4 il clouage
pourend4ise5 toujours
bloqué le jeu qui VI défendre
h6 il faut ramener la
dame6 ah c'est chaud comme partie c'est
une parti qui peut durer très longtemps
vu que c'est fermé elle est super elle
est rigolote et en fait elle doit se
dire quand même faut que je fasse durer
mais bon enfin là remarque il y a pas
assez de
d'avantage qui va revenir
H7 peut-être il faut défendre le P 6
aussi le cass se charge pour l'instant
att ouais ici roi bouge tour attention à
la dame hein parce que là on peut se la
faire et ouais tour su Go
elle a 5 secondes elle a plus beaucoup
de
temps bien joué ce petit cavalier à3 de
de costeno qui a du temps été jou sur
cavalier prend prend à4 il a un clouage
qui a l'air de pas être trop sympa quand
même fou prend à 4 t prend à 4 je sais
pas c'est quoi là un gros blunder gr
blunder complètement craqué mais bon
avec les 5 secondes elle peut encore
continuer cette position et tester
quelque chose ouais mais là ça va encore
échanger les dames qui a un coup moral
c'est de pièces de plus maintenant oh là
là deux pièces c'est trop Mo j'ai un P h
mais bon mais le pion le pion c ça va
être trop grave roi C8 elle va se cacher
on la connait celle-là roi B7 ouais B6
dame C3 k D4 après je peux vous dire que
ça va être trop dur
ouais fini allez
suivante et oui qui prend le large qui
prend le large maintenant avec de
pointance alors qu'elle avait 25
secondes contre 5 secondes c'est pour ça
qu'elle s'en veut Alexandra costho
qu'elle vient de filer la
boutique alors que il n'y avait pas de
de problématique
il reste encore 12 minutes pour revenir
encore jouableou mais bien
sûr
on a V qui B bien elle était touché par
cette défaite parce que elle éta en
train de mettre la pression et elle a
donner tout
seule c'est quand même regrettable il
vient de se passer pour elle c'est pas
fini et bien petite variante jeaime bien
aussi cette
petite cool c'est facile à jouer en plus
côté blanc je trouve que c'est un peu
plus difficile ave noir do surveiller
l'expansion
bon pour l'instant ça serit pas trop
c'est l'expansion à Dame des noir
finalement c'est c'est l'inverse de ce
qu'on souhaite mais bon ça va vite hein
donc vous voyez que IFAN peut-être C4
allez on y
va dame elle se
déclou veut cavalier h4croblement et
cavalier F5 et
G4 ça fonctionnait en plus c'était pas
trop mal dame 2 revient et elle a 15
secondes d'avance à
laule D4 est-ce qu'on joue C3 non elle
le
laisse est-ce qu'elle en joue C3 non
toujours pas non elle laisse C34 fou
prend sans doute pour l'instant qu'elle
veut juste manger fa caver3 la C4 aussi
hein sur A4 très bien joué c'est
thématique ouais les problèmes sur la
structure et là serait différent si mon
cavalier arrive en C4 avec les Blancs
elle ne peut plus perdre Alexandra
costenuk hein parce que ça serait
quasiment la défaite avec
elle perd là quasiment dans la
boî sera obligén sur les tris parties
suivantes ou mais là a 30 secondes de
retard et une position qui est qui est
compliqué et en plus que j'a par rapport
à sa stratégie tu vois que des parties
longues tu vois là F4 c'est qui va être
long
encore5
oh pas F4 oh là là quelle erreur de pas
jouer F4 c'était bizarre parce que av
tout fait mais peut-être qu'elle veut
juste qu'il se passe rien quoi ouais
ouais c'est c'est pas faux peut-être
qu'elle veut juste dame G4 etchanger les
pièces et dire bon ok on va la jouer
pendant 1 mais bon quand même F45 ça
sentait bon donc je pense qu'elle l'a
oublié après c'est facile pour nous de
dire parce qu'elle aait plus de temps et
comme elle essaie de mettre la pression
au temps ouf elle a peut-être jouer un
coup un peu vite oui oui c'est possible
peutê F4 d'ailleurs tour F1 F4 oh là oui
c'est pr le 5 c'est c'est tout ça c'est
lié un peu à la fatigue je pense tu sais
quand tu joues pendant pendant 2h3 à ton
meilleur niveau contre le numéro enfin
contre la numéro 1 mondiale tu fais un
super match à la fin des fois juste tuen
veux plus quoi trop dur quoi et là ça va
être long et dur pour Alexandra costeno
qui a craqué le pion G5 dame F3
tranquille maintenant j'aime bien ce
petit dame F3 dame D5 peut-être on visse
tour 2 c'est très bien tour1
ouais Aï aïe aïe aïe aïe c'est quasiment
ah peut-être F prend H4 c'est la
l'astuce
il faut à un moment donné essayer de
tenter ça mais bon il y a trop de
problème il y a qui va arriver aussi il
touours F7 F3 pénard fou D5 juste d dame
D5 voilà la joué dame B7 je te travaille
tu as 3 secondes au temps ouais il y a
plus de temps c'est horrible ro G2
horrible il reste 9 minutes à la pendule
IFAN qui prend bien son temps ouais mais
elle a du mal à gagner sa position parce
qu'elle a 13 secondes non mais elle
peut-être même pas la gagner hein tu
vois elle joue tranquille elle gagne du
temps pense vraiment qu'elle veut gagner
qu'elle va gagner parce c'est possible
mais elle doit bien se rendre compte que
mais en touchant à rien c'est c'est très
très
bien par rapport à la stratégie de match
c'est parfait c'est vrai faut juste pas
la perdre à la fin tu sais en ayant
vraiment abusé tu en fait elle touche
même pas la structure à un moment donné
bon ça y est elle fait F5 à un moment
donné il faut ESS de faire un truc mais
ouais
r peutêtre maintenant ouais c'est bien
ce que tu dis ion
ouis puis le pion je peux aller chercher
aussi peut-être il y a de P maintenant
là c'est gagnant l'chang gagnant
bien comment on va ah oui comment on va
progresser on va le H5 on arrivera si je
mets H5 je pourrais pousser je peux
aussi
ramer G4 fou
peut-être5 on fait F H6 bon écoute je
crois que c'est terminé ce
match terminé ave plus 3 avecon il reste
encore
gagne cette partie il faut encore gagner
de tu vois on est à
[Musique]
7 de tu commences la dernière ça ça va
ça va
ça temp quand même mais bon la confiance
je pense qu'elle a vraiment changé de
camp clairement ah oui mais là là c'est
clair et elle répète en plus c même
partie salut à toi j'aime les femmes
salut à toi sur le sur le chat ouais
c'est sympa Timo alors tour V
ouais deris tu as raison he la double
boulette ouais la la première ronde
enfin la première partie de bullette a
été incroyable
ouais c'était assez incroyable dam G3 il
y a quand même eu des des énormes
revirements parce que si on pensait
costuk légèrement favorite et si on suit
l'algorithme c'était ça
euh enfin les
prédictions mais en fait c'était
vraiment hyper aléatoire la première
partie des fois conditionne un retour en
force d'une des joueuses un peu comme
quand Alexandra kenou est elle même
revenu à un moment du début de de ce
speedess et là maintenant à
malgré l'avantage promis par la J on a
du mal quand même à l'imaginer gagner
trois parties sur tris parce que wifan
joue plusion plus vite ah oui c'est cl
peutêtre est-ce qu'on a le droit de
faire ass toutou pour tu sais bloquer de
manière maline ouais c'est la partie
bien joué voilà B5 à5 et sur a 5 B5
voilà et là atttion C4 roi a 7 sans
doute va être joué fou B7 fou B7 bizarre
fou B7 quand même mais bon bon mant
juste tenir ou va essayer de tenir le
plus longtemps possible alors après la
positionme pas trèsandme
pour pour les tu as raison avec F4
f5and pass en force est que tu
mets bien jou
est il faut
ouvrirtion dommage que la tour soit pas
en C8 pour les
noirs
pour V vite
passer
mais qui pe tomb
par M de rien il est perdu donc en fait
elle va peutêtre gagner en force envoyer
le pion A4 ouais mais pas trop pas
tropenvoyer parce que tour qui peut
toujours
revenir reste 4 minutes
40 ça m l' compromis quand Mme ça m'a
l' ça le plus une seconde pars voyez
bien
l'astuceent longtemps elle devra jouer
jusqu'au bout et oui à 4 c'était le
thème he stouf ouais on revient à 3 tour
à derrire
ouais là ça ça risque d'être compromis
hop je répète je ramène je répète elle a
tout intérêt à répéter elle peut pas B
la nul c'est terminé m n termin c'est
terminé
et il y a plus rien à faire
là c'est foutu maintenant
an elle a plus qu'à faire durer bah il
reste 4 minutes faut juste jouer en fait
voilà Alexandra COS qui est d'ailleurs
motivé on voit que par l'idée de de
faire une partie ultra rapide avec ce
H5 un peu hors de propos revient en C8
waouh
ouis c'est juste que là elle est en tilt
elle sait qu'elle a perdu le match et
qu'elle était pas loin de faire quelque
chose pas loin du tout même si ça c'est
dans le finalement tu vois dans le 1 + 1
tu as vuou 4 et demi 05 comme quoi
bah peut vite Viller hein on le sait le
on avait dit la confiance il y a pas
cavalier F6 oh il y a cavalier F6 tout
finin avec même même qu'av les D6 je
crois que l'air intéressant ouais B la
totale et en plus ou fan avec la
confiance elle risque de peut-être
sortir une bonne partie ouais B4 TR bien
elle va jouer elle va jouer à la main
cette partie on le sent ouais et on voit
bien que c'est horrible même c'est3
presque enamb buulette je pourrais te
faire un truc comme ça juste pour euh
ouais là c'est
dur 3 bien joué ouais c'est juste perdu
en fait il reste de minutes
50 on connaî maintenant le nom de la
première finaliste on peut le dire
finiste ouais
an bon qui était quand même considéré
comme favorite dans ce match bien sûr
mais sur ce match elle a montré que ah
oui a clairement montré de très très
belles choses franchement on pensait
qu'elle allait même gagner pendant très
longtemps de deux premiers
set regarde la tour h deux cavaliers qui
font oh là là se regardent peu comme ça
abandonn et
puis voilà alors là ça doit être dur
quand tu es à plus 4 et tu as sombrer
comme ça ça doit être plus plus dur de
le jouer ton petit ton petit Bullet oui
non là tu as plus envie là tu as plus
envie 5 et dem 0 de c'est dommage parce
que tu vois elle avait mené dans les
deux premiers set et puis en
Bullet en bullette elle a été plus
stable on peut dire
ouanelle elle a joué beaucoup plus
bizarrement sans doute moins juste d'un
point de vue théorique mais très
rapidement en posant des problèmes et en
embrouillant toujours son adversaire
donc voilà
belle leçon quand même au niveau de bah
du Bullet moi je suis particulièrement
incapable tu le sais dans ce genre de
cadence
mais je trouve que c'est une bonne leçon
de jouer très pratique ouais je sais que
to
çaou j'ae bienis pe comment faire tu
sais comment faire làtit ben après là
c'est du Bullet mais c'est a un
incrément c'est quand même diff c'est ça
c'est un peu particulier faut faire
gaffe de pas faire n'importe quoi non
plus c'est différentop Blu ouais parce
que bon le bullet0 c'est quand même
différent en une plus une je joue jamais
oui oui c'est particulier tout à fait
reprends 6 fou7 per G4
ouis il av cavalier prend G4 peut-être
directement qui mér avec des histoires
de tour prend f3ouf je me disais que ça
pouvait être aussi Show
Time tour
prend7 là de toute façon je pense
qu'elle y est plus du tout hein elle
joue des
coups pas au hasard mais presque si vous
voulaz c'està-dire queah elle en peut
plus quoi oui sa qu'elle a perdu et
puis exact cavalier en l'air en un coup
alors elle pourrait abandonner mais elle
pourit aussi continuer ah non elle a
quand même elle a quand même deux pièces
pour la tour donc ça va encore
mais il reste 28 secondes dans le temps
et si la partie se termine avant il y
aura encore une autre partie derrière
sinon ser termin ou je pense que les
deux joueuses elle a juste envie de
continuer fan pour qu'il ait pas
d'autres parties je la vois pas abandonn
dans le sens que bah déjà la position
est jouable et qu'en plus même vis-à-vis
de son adversaire je pense qu'elle a
envie même que ça se termine pour les
deux joueuses il y a des grosses bêtises
là le le le match est terminé c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir la
motivation pour les deux joueuses
maintenant non ouais et ça joue juste
des coups et c'est terminé le temps est
arrivé à zéro donc on va avoir on va
avoir une gagnante une première
finaliste après bon aès cette partie
mais on sait déjà que c'est ouifan qui
se qualifie pour la finale contre harika
ou contre Katarina Lano donc on va
montrer juste après là j'ai je vais vous
montrer les petits les petites scènes
que j'ai pas une favorite pour pour
demain
euh oui je pense que lagno quand même
plus d'expérience dans ces formats là
ouais mais c'est vrai elle a déjà gagné
en plus cette compétition mais ah r
forte impression à chaque fois que je la
vois jouer je trouve qu'elle joue hyper
bien après le le le format c'est pas
forcément que la prime beau jeu c'est la
constance les petits trics tactiques et
et ça c'est encore différent c'est un
peu plus complet que de manière générale
Catarina est quand même plus forte oui
et donc sur un format comme ça ça
normalement quand tu es plus fort aussi
on va voir un math esthétique pour finir
stouf on n pas loin du main ouais il a
un réseau il y a perpè déjà si j'ai vu
la jauge qui montait ouais apparemment
il y avit pas mal H6 c'est peut-être
l'inverse oh il y a ma en tout cas si
elle termine sur une belle partie c'est
déjà ça rage 2 ro G3 et abandon je
menace mat voilà c'est mat fou pu on
prend jolie la fin est jolie ok je vais
quand même lui mettre son petit point
c'est bon la position finale ouais ouais
c'est mat
imparable mat imparable donc 9 et demi
donc 12 et5i 9 et demi he pour pour
ouifan qui va prendre son premier ticket
pour la finale alors je montre un petit
peu le bracket qui est ici vous voyez
avec
IFAN qui marque son nom sur la première
marche de la finale et on va jouer
maintenant lagno contre harika donc
demain à partir de 17h vous aurez la
finale enfin la deè de finale et la
grande finale se jouera lundi aussi à
17h et ces deux matchs encore toujours
en compagnie de Kevin terieux et de
moi-même donc donc voilà merci en en
tout cas à tous ou je te vois plus Kevin
j'ai voulu mettre la la la belle la
belle scène mais comme j'avais rglé les
caméras plein de fois et ben je te vois
plus donc merci en tout cas à tous
d'avoir suivi le stream avec nous merci
beaucoup à toi Kevin ouais merci sou CIT
cool en tout cas format hyper agréable à
commenter puis un match Chéré donc on
s'est bien on s'est bien régalé quoi
entre ces deux super B joueuse avec des
rebondissements de folie on a vu
costenuk à un moment sombrer dès le
début puis après on l'a vu presque
gagnante et en fait IFAN est revenu dans
le dans le 10 dans le 1+ 1 donc c'était
c'était formidable ouais c'est ça donc
demain 17h deè demi fininale entre Kaa
et lagno on vous attend nombreux sur
twitch sur sur Youtube et je vous dis de
passer une bonne soirée à demain
etain et et et
voilà petit bug sur la fin à bientôth
demain à demain ciao ciao